This episode of Your Mom's house is brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress,
the only online mattress company that provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Well,
go to your mom's house,
Christina.
This episode of Your Mom's house is brought to you by better help.com go to
better help.com/y m h and you can get a counselor to start working with you
within 24 hours.
Um,
better help provides online counseling services,
which is really something that,
you know,
we've endorsed for our own personal life for a long time.
Can we?
I've been in therapy for 10 years and it's been the one thing that's helped me
the most and I recommend it for everybody.
I don't know how people go through life without seeing a therapist.
It's the one investment you should make in yourself for your happiness,
for the,
for your rest of the rest of your life.
It's true.
And these are licensed therapists that are available worldwide through multiple
modes of communication,
text,
chat,
video,
phone,
again,
licensed professionals that can work with you.
It's important to note this is not a crisis line.
Uh,
but this is for somebody that wants to engage in ongoing therapy.
It's quite affordable.
And even if you can't afford that,
there is financial aid available.
Uh,
but uh,
you know,
we can't,
we can't endorse or stress enough how much has helped the two of us.
I actually got jealous of how happy and,
and just,
uh,
you know,
content and like you became from going to therapy.
So I started probably,
I don't know,
five,
six years ago and I've been really,
yeah,
there have been really happy with it.
The thing is people walk around with a depression,
anxiety and there's no need to suffer.
You can see somebody,
you can talk to somebody and better help.com/why?
Mh?
Yeah,
it's secure.
It's pervasive.
It's professional.
It's convenient.
Go to better health.com/why and and agency.
If it's right for you.
Ooh.
Chips
in the fall.
It's in a bowl.
That's a big,
big news.
Shit is major right here.
So,
all right.
I've been working on this for a long time,
but it's finally here.
I can announce that my new tour.
Ah,
take it down.
Tour is coming.
Two weeks.
City near you in 2019 kicks off in January and it's going to run through the
year.
Um,
for people asking that like if you're coming to October,
November shows like Boise,
Sacramento,
Philadelphia,
all those,
uh,
yeah,
that's,
that's not a new,
that's not going to be separate from the stuff in January that that's the tour.
But as part of the tour is what you're,
this is called branding.
We're branding it starting in 2019 but yeah,
you're seeing the new hour.
Obviously if you're coming to these shows in the next couple of months,
um,
there's a lot of cities,
I am not going to list them all.
And by the way,
this is the most fun part of like posting something and explaining it in detail.
Yeah.
There's like a post,
here's the first leg of the day
tour,
but don't worry 20 more cities are coming.
International cannot market Canada to first comments.
How come Toronto's not on the list?
Right?
Why aren't you coming to Minneapolis?
All right dude.
I am.
Why can't you read?
Why?
Why come?
Why come you not coming to Canada and you're like,
I just told you why it says in the thing of full Canadian tourists coming,
dammit.
What about Vancouver?
How come you're not here?
Maybe your fans can't read because maybe they can't.
I can.
No,
I'm serious.
All right.
We are coming to Austin,
bitch.
I'm coming to Austin.
It's obviously going to be the second half.
Yeah.
What is the face of Fart?
And you do that.
How do you follow the new,
I don't think this then this is the word
poster.
He's like,
what is the quality of this?
Um,
anyway,
no,
I am really excited.
Uh,
I added a fourth show in Philly if I didn't mention fourth shift.
The fourth part show at the Merriam theater.
Those are life is they're all on sale now.
Go to Thomson [inaudible] Dot Com.
Click on the tour.
It all goes on sale Friday.
This Friday.
The entire tour is on sale.
Thank you all.
Your mom's house listeners for support.
I appreciate it.
Um,
Jean,
what do you guys,
what will you be going to Boise boy seed.
Did you,
are you coming?
Oh,
I also got like,
it would be,
yeah.
Cool if you came to to Boise and I go,
but I'm there and like in a couple of weeks.
Yeah.
Uh,
I didn't look at that.
Yeah.
So what do you,
what are you suggesting people do?
Read your calendar online,
perhaps,
dude.
I mean,
it's in the fucking caption of the post.
Okay.
All right,
good.
Oh,
okay.
Mommy's November 24th and man,
Diego,
California.
My 7:00 PM show is sold the fuck out.
We've added a 10:00 PM show,
House of Bruise November 24th.
That's after the holidays.
Listen,
your,
your family's over.
It's time to get the fuck out of the house.
That's,
that's Saturday.
You know what I'm saying?
I know what you're saying.
Drag them to the show.
Bring them out or run away from your family and come see me.
Do my brand new hour.
It's not stuff this,
I have a Netflix special coming out in October.
Going to be different from that shit.
You know what I'm saying?
Never.
Not Grinding seven days a week.
Y'all hustle hard.
December 7th fill her up.
Delphia at the punchline.
Uh,
that,
that one's almost sold out where it looks like we're going to be adding a 10:00
PM show as well.
A Jew Dork titties December 8th sold out 8:00 PM show,
added a 10 30 show at the Grammercy theater in judo,
ORC,
titties tickets at Christina p online.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm Ryan producing direct and all this shit.
That's what's up.
Okay man,
I'm so ready.
We this such an exciting episode.
It's very exciting.
We have friends joining us.
We have a lot to cover,
a lot of things to discover.
You know what,
these uh,
base case,
right?
Facebook.
I like her.
She clarified as the face fire.
What these,
uh,
I don't,
I don't these right.
You can infer what face farts are by the try it and the thing called face Bart
didn't try.
You should try it.
My specialty is mass farting,
mass bus all the time.
I don't know.
It's a fun.
Can you make a Maga show for me so I process Eh,
eh,
face of fire.
So stupid.
All right,
Jean,
let's press play.
Let's get going.
Ready?
Go for it.
Let's do it.
This is one of the more bizarre stories we've seen in a very,
very long time.
And Gilbert man is accused of duping caregivers and the thinking that he was
special needs.
I've been paying them to change his diaper and bathe him.
Yes.
Don't bring in one month
we'll go to your mom's house.
Yeah,
I love this guy.
Changed my diaper.
Now do you think he was wearing a diaper?
Bef like that's his thing and he's like,
God,
this is so tedious.
Changing these diapers I need,
I need help the caregivers.
I read this article.
Well let's,
we'll show you some stuff,
but I'm sure you're great.
Um,
I'll tell you what I read in the article.
Yeah.
Marketing is one of the more bizarre stories that I've reported on.
Police say a grown man who had caregivers help change his diaper and basin
itself really never needed help at all.
What's your full name and date of birth?
Nine Paul and even chocolate.
August 18th,
1987 police say this man,
30 year old Paul Machaca pretended to have down syndrome.
Okay.
According to court documents,
he posed as a woman named Amy on a website called [inaudible] dot com looking
for caregivers to change his diaper and bathe him regularly.
A total of three caregivers would end up falling for this scheme.
Can I ask you something so far?
Where's the harm?
Well,
here's the harm.
I mean,
let's just say,
what's the problem here?
Let me,
let's just say like he step for them on pay now,
but he's posing as special needs.
I agree.
Cool.
Where's the harm?
Can't,
can't he just be like,
look,
I enjoy wearing a diaper.
I want someone to change.
Do you think it's a fetish?
Is that this is,
and he's not going to a dom like ms face forwarder,
right?
He should have gone to,
but at the end of the day,
I mean,
they're just changing his diet.
I and bathing him,
but there,
but that's their real caregivers.
Like at the,
it's a manipulation and it's not cool.
It's not nice.
But,
but he posed as somebody named Amy,
I think that's,
no.
So Amy,
Amy,
I think was the online thing where he was like,
I'm,
I'm Amy.
Can you help?
You know,
Chris or whatever.
Oh,
he's a character.
He's a character.
Special Ed needs special,
especially needs
needs.
I don't know.
Don't understand the f phase.
A fart is the same eh,
Healy document state.
The caregiver's became suspicious when he aggressively would date.
He needed to be cleaned to better in certain areas.
Okay.
Erica,
I need to get cleaned better down there down there.
That there's always a pervy angle with dudes.
Yeah,
of course.
Always.
Always are so nasty.
No limits to how far we will go.
Why are,
what's the difference between nasty,
why aren't you guys as nasty?
Because we don't,
because you guys are in the power position in society.
You guys are the ones who can rape and kill and torture.
But then were the ones that are submissive because of our physical strength.
I think that's,
what does that have to do with,
why is it that you like you can manipulate me,
right?
Like if I don't give you what you want,
you can forcibly haul me down and hurt me.
Jesus.
So like that's why you fuck with people.
It's a power thing.
But wait,
why does Louie CK jerk off in front of people?
Do you know what I'm saying?
It's a power thing.
So this guy is just flexing his power.
Yeah.
Instead of just clean me better downstairs
and that.
But he asks that you have to do it special needs,
you have to do it more.
Better is dirty still there.
You
had to do like Forrest Gump.
Mom,
Mama said that if you have a dirty chocolate backside then you can't sit for
dinner and supper.
That Mama made right?
Like this guy was basically doing a Forrest Gump impression the whole time.
So I mean,
do you think like he would drop character or sometimes and they're like,
wait a minute.
Oh,
I'm sure they were like,
hm,
you're not specialty probably.
Yeah.
The article I read was that they were bathing him,
uh,
that all three caregivers were like every,
bathing.
He had an erection for green bay.
It's weird.
You mean this guy is just not a straight up needs a diaper change.
The report says one care giver fallen men chocolate and knocked on the front
door.
At date,
she was greeted by his parents who later to police their son does not have down
syndrome and did not need assistance with bathing or using the restroom.
They had to confirm it with the parents.
That's pretty funny.
I've been washing your son's nuts and uh,
these nuts saying f g t o r t e d
but this is what men Chalkah said to the judge and my mom has paper and my mom
and dad both have paperwork to put that.
Oh,
okay.
I'm starting to talk to my dad about getting me some help and gave me into a
counselor.
But he does have a low Iq.
Does that not qualify?
I know,
I think just the way that he even stated that shows his Iq is too high.
Oh,
it to be low Iq.
you mean like if you know you have no,
I'm not saying you can't.
Like if you had a low Iq you could,
you could be aware of it,
but I just feel like he has too much awareness to low Iq as he's claiming.
You know,
you know after I delivered Julian,
you have a low Iq.
I had a such low Iq.
This nice nurse washed my virgin for me and she did not like it up,
but it was one of the most wonderful.
Thanks.
Yeah,
once I got over the humiliation,
the embarrassment of it,
I was like,
I could get used to this having it cleaned,
someone else doing it.
I would love for someone to come and wash my backside and put a die die on you.
That'd be great.
I don't know if I want to shit in my diaper though.
This guy does.
I know.
That's really,
really good.
I love it.
You got to love the game.
You gotta love the diaper game.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't mind paying in a diaper,
but I think you're right.
Browns are like,
isn't it mashes up against you and everything?
Yeah,
bad.
But I still would like the sponge bath.
Yeah.
And then I go watch more down there and needs more.
So you need to make it more clean.
It's still dirty down there.
And then I just look to the side.
It's still dirty.
And she goes,
I think it's clean now.
I go,
no,
it's still dirty.
Yeah,
like that
one of the victims also spoke out.
It has affected my work as well.
I've actually missed work for that and I think that it should be held with
either a substantial bond amount or where he would not be released until the
next court date because I have fear for my safety in regards to that as well as
my family and friends because I didn't bring my family and friends around him.
Oh,
so now it's actually worse than,
I mean those caregivers are so vulnerable.
Like these people are angels that do work like this,
that show up at some stranger's house there at totally in the vulnerable
position here.
Like my goodness,
this poor woman touched my booboo,
knocked on the door to see if the family would speak with us.
You didn't answer.
Oh no kidding.
And chaga faces 10 counts of sexual abuse charges.
He'll be back in court on September 17th the morning live.
Courtney Griffin box 10 news.
They didn't want seeing 10 counts and that's a lot.
I thought he was just facing like a posing,
you know,
as a special needs person know.
Just like,
uh,
I don't know.
Some type of impersonation charge.
I didn't realize it was it's abuse though,
to make these women,
I'm assuming bookies face by face mark.
Let living explain.
Oh,
I put a spot.
Yeah.
I kept this,
uh,
Ooh.
This is,
this was in the,
uh,
on,
on the,
on the television.
Yeah.
You're going down the third base.
Nice blame Machado.
Liverpool soon retarded.
Oh yeah.
I know the Albert who holds a comedy.
Yeah.
Pools are worded.
That's what it sounded.
When I say it sounds like
retarded.
I mean,
what the things it sounds like they should,
the focus on,
well,
there's,
man,
there needs to be outraged.
We have to get that man fire.
Dare you say he's Dominican.
You don't call them are worded.
What does that have to do with his,
yeah,
he's still a baseball player.
Treat him with respect.
Jesus.
Cool.
Sounds retarded.
Gosh,
super disrespectful.
Yeah.
How old is Albert Poo holes now?
For Real?
He's been around a minute,
right?
Yeah.
He was close to my age,
so he's probably 63 now.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The what show was it?
I wanted to watch with you last night and you said it wrong.
I've been making funny all day.
Oh,
sharp objects.
I see the shirt.
You go,
are we going to watch the sharp objects?
I'm like,
not these jobs.
Then I started,
you didn't catch what?
I started doing nerd.
I started looking at other titles and I said the in front of all of them,
of course.
How many titles has been,
Gosh,
you want to finish the Ozarks?
Oh my God.
I have not.
I still,
do you ever feel like with certain,
especially because we work in comedy and were comedians and we,
you know,
we're just around it all the time.
You forget how funny some you take it for granted because they'd been around for
a minute.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
How talented,
how funny some people are.
Yeah.
Where you go,
somebody brings them up.
You're like,
yeah,
you know?
Of course,
yeah,
they're awesome,
but then you're like,
whatever.
Because it's,
it's like it's,
it's in your head that they'd been around you watching your own specialist again
and you're like,
I'm blown away by me.
No,
I am blown away by Sasha Baron Cohen.
Oh,
Mike me.
I was thinking the same thing.
You forget how fucking talented that guy is.
Guy.
We finally got to starting who is America?
Oh my God,
who is America showtime series that came out earlier this year actually I ran
into Metzker Kurt Metzger a couple of weeks ago at the store and he's a writer
on on this.
I saw his name on the credits and we were talking briefly,
but he's like,
oh,
you haven't seen it?
I go,
no.
He was like,
and it I think is actually what prompted me to finally do it because he's so
Kurt so funny that when he said like I could tell how much joy he got from
working on and seeing the show,
I was like,
I got to check this out.
I have laughed harder watching four episodes of that so far than anything I can
recall in the last couple of years.
Yeah.
That's how funny that guy has to me.
He's amazing.
He does these other characters for those of you don't know who,
so I should bear in is,
he's the guy that did Ali g and Bruno and Borat and the dictator.
I mean,
and then he's doing one or who was America and he's got these great characters.
One is a left wing NPR,
ultra liberal.
He's like,
I'm a privileged white male.
He says,
I think the most dangerous chemical in the world is testosterone and then has
like a big pot belly and he has a ponytail and he,
you know,
he goes around interviewing conservative people.
It's this stuff.
And then he's got like ultra conservative sectors.
God,
he's trying to take back the word pedophile.
He's like,
ah,
because I love kids.
So I'm proud to call myself one.
And these guys like,
no,
yeah,
let's reclaim that word.
And he's like,
you're a pedophile to,
and the guys like,
stop saying that.
But he has so many great,
he has a an like an Alex Jones like character where the uh,
the thing says library truth Berry and that's [inaudible] dot org and he has
these nutty conspiracy theories.
Yeah.
Um,
then he has that Israeli um,
sorry.
Yeah.
Terrorist training.
So,
but like the scenarios are so ridiculous,
but he's just so fucking funny man.
Scary too is that he finds actual politicians and he fucks with them and you see
how super are awarded.
A lot of our representatives are in government.
Yeah.
Terrifying.
How they are not like one of them takes,
it takes no encouragement for him to just shout the end word like yeah.
With television cameras rolling and dope and he ran,
he had to retire.
He had to resign after this.
Yeah,
I know.
Yeah.
Crazy.
Screaming it.
Yeah.
It's,
it's fantastic.
Is it showtime or Hbo?
Showtime.
Sasha Baron Cohen.
He's his,
he's married to a funny lady to what's her name is Amy.
No,
I left Fisher.
Fisher.
She's finding too,
yeah,
she is calm.
Many people get married.
Yeah.
It's great.
I don't,
but it's cool.
He's a,
he is so funny and I cannot endorse that show enough.
I don't know if that shows getting enough credit and I don't think,
I think part of it too is there like it's Sacha Baron Cohen.
Like some people are just like,
oh that guy who does think,
but you see what he's doing in this and it's,
it's so fucking it.
Do you feel like he's,
he's bitten Ben kind of written off in a way.
And I,
that's what I'm saying is in movies or don't they do well then the dictator do
well or,
I don't know why I did fair.
I think it was probably in comparison to Tibor at which crushed the box off
where I was amazed.
They always,
you know,
you're always weighed upon like what your last movie did.
Yeah.
And,
and I,
I bet you it's hard to do the show because so many people recognize him for
sure.
That's why he's in like incredible prosthetics.
Really good for the show.
I was like,
damn,
I wouldn't,
well they probably spend a day getting him into each,
you know,
could you imagine?
Oh my God,
what a nightmare when he goes to,
he goes to some kind of rural town in Arizona and he tells me he's got great
news that the world's or did you like the second biggest mosque in the world?
In their town.
But the funny thing is that also people do not care to hide who they are.
Yeah.
With cameras there.
No like,
what the fuck?
We don't want a mosque here.
He's like,
no,
it's going to be great.
It's gonna be like a first class mosque.
And they were like,
we don't give a shit.
And then,
and then he's like,
here's a look at the future of what it's going to be like on your streets.
And it's like,
you know,
men walking their camels everywhere wearing those robes.
I don't know what the male version of things are written.
And it's all in Arabic.
Arabic.
So funny.
And they're so pissed.
Yes.
What's really interesting is a revealing,
um,
just how racist Americans are against Middle Easterners and Muslims.
So it's like every other segment of that,
of that shit.
Every other segment you're like,
wow,
everyone's really racist.
Yeah.
It's a good show.
Yeah,
it's pretty,
pretty great,
man.
He's great.
Now,
have you been watching a new murder show or as I like to say,
studying for the future?
No doubt about it.
Yeah.
You finish Ozark on behind.
Yeah,
I finished it.
It's great.
Goddammit.
I,
I'm so,
what are you watching it?
What's the new serial killer lineup?
They're not,
I'm actually getting into some spiritual stuff.
Good.
No,
I am.
I'm trying to get in touch with that other side.
I found this pastor that I'm really into.
Oh.
Should knock on Amazon.
How you pass the incursion.
Real world problems.
We're definitely living in La as a bitch.
Let me tell you something.
You must be a bitch like showing yes,
I cost.
I'm the counseling pastor while y'all motherfucking pastor ain't doing a gut.
No,
I'm good.
Okay.
I like him already.
See that's why I'm into him.
I'm the cousin pastor that use my platform to raise $6,000 father's mother who
was going through a place where these other equally as none functioning as
vassals wasn't doing.
I'm motherfucking thing in this city right now.
That bothers you that I'm a constant hassle then get your motherfucking head off
my damn page.
Plaintiff.
Damn simple.
See,
I don't play.
It's about being real.
It's about the truth and I don't give a damn.
You bitches.
You Hoe ass Nigga Zealand.
Yeah,
lot
of.
I love it.
A lot of pastors don't talk like it,
but I liked that he talks like this.
I mean,
does it say in the Bible you can't curse?
Does it say that shit?
I don't think it says Ho ass n word.
No,
but it doesn't say you can't curse.
God never said thou shalt not curse.
That's not one of the commandments.
True.
God is real.
God blesses.
Blesses.
What Tom?
Well you mean to find a no,
please.
Ah,
it was a different time when we could record that.
Tell him the truth.
Just like it was soap,
Mitch,
but Oh,
I'm going to pick you up so you don't have to worry about the wrong thing.
Yes,
I curse Jesus.
Probably curse.
That's right.
Just to be sitting there looking at you.
[inaudible] name's nick roses in,
damn,
I made that.
I love him.
I kind of,
what can I tell you?
Because there is this misconception that this language thing is silly.
It's silly that people who don't curse are better or more moral than people that
do curse.
It's just,
it's nonsense.
Your morality has nothing to do,
right?
No.
So silly.
There are great people,
like we always have this thing about in comedy,
the scariest comics.
Yeah.
Are the ones who are squeaky clean.
Oh,
right.
Look at Bill Cosby,
the psycho number one.
Ah,
yeah.
And this thing and little low.
Yeah.
No,
it's true.
And it's true.
He's the biggest asshole of a mall for sure.
Yeah.
He's a serial rapist,
but yeah,
but it's,
it is true clean and that he's very clean.
And then these really deprived acts that say the nastiest Valvia things usually.
Usually the sweetest.
Yeah.
Most trustworthy look approachable people.
Dave Attell.
Yeah,
I'd say a little sweetheart.
And one of the Nastier,
nastier acts,
you gotta be so nasty.
The one of the nicest human beings alive.
Yeah.
I'm trying to think who else is nasty.
So nasty,
so nasty.
You're kind of nasty.
I'm a little nasty.
People would say that you and I are kind of nasty,
but I'm a sweet boy.
Were the nicest people.
I'm a sweet boy or the nicest.
Yeah,
I'm way nice or the new.
I'm the Nice Champ.
You are the nice champ.
You just gave that to me like that.
You could take nice.
Really.
I think,
I think people would disagree if they met us.
That's not true.
People approach me all the time.
They're always nice to them.
I'm never not nice to people who approach me really.
Of course you're but you're not.
You're a little standoffish.
I don't think I'm staying off it.
I'm saying I'm not going out there like hello.
You wreck it like I'm not that.
I'm not soliciting.
Not I'm not.
Yeah.
No,
I don't.
I don't solicit it now.
I know what I'm saying.
I I don't.
I'm saying if anyone ever approaches me,
I always am really nice.
So Am I.
Yeah.
I'm the manners champ though.
I've better manners than you knew.
No,
that's not true.
That's not true.
It's just out of ignorance,
so I'm just not as classy.
I wasn't raised as classy.
He would at least tip your hat and my way for that.
You're like the,
I mean,
yeah.
Yeah,
I would say that you're like the decorum champ.
Like you know how to act right.
I don't know how to act right and a lot of situations,
but that's just cause I was raised like a fucking animal.
I've told you in certain situations,
what are you doing right now?
You got it all right.
All right.
Or sometimes I'll ask you,
I'll ask you like how do I act normal?
Like what?
What do normal,
what would a normal person do here?
But you've helped me.
Yeah.
I was just telling somebody the other day,
like you,
you made me a normal human being.
You kind of,
you taught me how to be American and civilized.
I was a Hungarian wild dog before.
Yeah.
And now no fucking lady.
I'm a mom.
Yeah,
mom.
Mother of two.
Um,
this just came in and I haven't read it,
but I know Tom is bad is right.
No,
no,
I think you're going to like it.
Look,
you can read it.
I haven't read it,
but I just started reading on my damn glasses.
I forgot them.
Okay.
Tom Is not right or die is the subject to high mommies.
I was watching episode 40 65 and you were discussing whether Christina was a
true writer die if she would turn Tom informed murder.
I was later discussing this with my boyfriend and he brought up a very
interesting point.
Tom,
is the true betrayer of the ride or die relationship.
This is because Christina said she would only turn Tom in for a premeditated
killing and in this scenario,
Tom is the first one to betray the relationship loyalty because he did not
disclose the planning of the murder.
As we know from all of Tom Psycho murder shows,
all premeditated killings involve a planning phase.
Therefore,
upon Tom Planning to kill a Barista that got his Venti iced coffee,
extra ice with a splash of soy order wrong.
Oh,
this guy got it wrong.
He would tell Christina his plant if he was a true writer,
die.
Therefore,
Tom,
Yana is not a true right,
a dye.
So Christina,
what not?
I'd have to maintain her ride or die status after the murder and,
and can turn him and absolutely love your podcast.
Give to my end tight piss on me.
Beat me.
Rub,
rub,
rub Shelby from Canada.
Um,
oh,
thank you.
Shelby from camp.
Here's,
let's discuss for real.
Have an interesting point.
I guess we're kind of conflating though different scenarios today.
The word,
well,
I'm saying so there could be the idea that I'm a,
I have a premade premeditated planned.
Yes.
That usually would take place.
There'd be like the stocking period lying in.
Wait.
Okay,
so that's one scenario.
There's also this scenario where I see the Barista,
so it's not necessarily preplanned,
it's more of a passion now,
but I told you in that case I might help you out because it's a,
it's a,
you fucked up in the moment.
Correct.
And I would take mercy on your soul and I would go,
all right,
let's figure this shit out because we got kids.
However,
Yana yeah,
I would probably still have to leave because if you're capable of that kind of
crime of passion with a Barista,
I'm going to be next or the children.
So I'd help you get rid of the body and then I leave Ya.
Yeah,
but premeditation.
I'm calling cops nine one one bro.
You're done.
Well because you're out of your fucking mind.
You need to be taken off the streets.
Yeah,
I guess I would say it's safe to say that your not an f g t r e d because the
real,
for those of you who have been playing this game all along and we're wondering
and guessing,
what does it mean?
We finally can tell you.
It means for girls that ride till death and there's a very limited number of FTD
RTDs out there,
uh,
for girls that ride till death and here,
oh,
you have your one l here,
but it's correct in the shirt,
uh,
four girls that ride till death,
women's black tea.
It's for women only.
It's,
I think a great gift.
If you're a guy and you want to salute your lady for being a ride or die.
Yeah.
You get her,
her very own F,
g t r t t shirt.
Now this is a shirt for the ladies only.
It's ladies only.
So this is a women's cut shirt.
And I'll describe it for those listeners who are not watching us on youtube.
It's got the letters,
And what's that font called?
Kind of a gothic.
It is Kinda Gothic,
kind of Rad Cholo type.
And then it says four girls that ride till death under it with a chain.
It's hard.
Really cool.
Yeah.
I like,
it's kind of golf and I like it.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
get it for your lady.
Get it for yourself.
It's ladies only.
It's,
you know,
you're the ultimate Ftt RTDs you ladies that,
uh,
will stay by your man just because he are you saying I'm not an FTT RTD?
Clearly not clearly not.
Yeah.
Um,
uh,
oh by the way,
do you remember this dude who was like,
Hey,
what's cracking was cracking?
It was cracking.
And um,
he wants,
you know,
he wants chicks to,
he wants any chick of any race to come to his house.
Yeah,
yeah.
Hey Yo,
yo,
Yo,
Yo was cracking much quicker.
Which quacking actor.
Hey listen,
white,
brown,
Asian,
that whole thing,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I was talking about,
we're talking about get wet and I was like,
well,
I mean the way I know get wet means PCP.
Uh,
Santana was saying dipping a joint in formaldehyde.
Sure.
Okay.
So I always knew as a PCP,
he's a formaldehyde.
Guess what it actually is for this man.
But it's water.
What?
He loves water.
No,
I swear to you,
I swear to you wonder what the fuck.
I love you all and you know what?
Water has no color.
None.
If you can't low about me doing slam some water,
hit that door inc and be good after Lavista baby.
Yeah.
This dude has like a pretty sizable social media following and like he has a big
Twitter following and get wet for him.
His drink a bunch of water.
Um,
I think he's been well,
listen to our show.
Hey,
let's fucking do this together.
What the fuck this guy thinks he's the water chimp.
Look,
this is fucking bullshit.
You know what?
We know somebody else had drinks like that.
Me.
No someone else but
okay.
It's because he's,
he's high all day I think.
Spoken to Joy.
Oh right.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
You don't,
I don't know really know what you should have better rush water are doing.
I have to hold water.
Hey love you have a good day.
Stay wet.
Glasgow sarge today low.
Always ask a little bit of baby.
Yeah,
he's a happy dude.
He's happy dude.
Uh,
is definitely styles looking me for being water champ.
Absolutely.
We should see how much water this guy can really chug.
But this guy cheese is,
is like super into water.
Where's your water?
I'm just curious.
Are you hydrating today Tom?
I'm pretty damn sure.
Yo Yo yo yo Yo.
Yo Yo,
if Friday,
let's get the fucking weekend to do stuff that I don't know if the world have
really ready for this mass k pass that blunt.
Boom headed up man.
Top in space.
You hear me?
But I'm going to do it.
Okay.
See
Ya.
He's all about his water.
That's what I'm saying.
So weird.
We've got to reach out to him,
I guess,
but I feel like he's stealing my role.
My Thunder.
Yeah.
I'm the water champ.
Did you know that?
That's bullshit.
No,
I've been drinking.
Guys.
Watch these past episodes on Youtube.
How many times do you ever see Tom Dry?
Give you a moment in time.
A moment.
That's all I give you.
I'm going to have blue band splice together.
How I've been drinking so much water.
And you'll ask,
but what I'm saying is you get a little bit while you're,
while we're filming this,
there's not cameras rolling.
24 seven on us.
Oh my God.
By my bedside.
How many bottles of water are there right now?
Like this one?
No,
like for,
I've actually really been somebody who tries to get my friends to invest more.
Yeah.
I can't believe how little some of my friends think about it.
Yeah,
it is true.
You should start thinking about it and,
and kind of earlier in life.
Better earlier than later.
Of course.
Why not?
Start now,
dude.
You don't have to have a lot of money to do it.
You just got to start doing it.
Yeah,
exactly.
Hey,
that looks really good on you.
Thanks.
You Teddy fresh.
Yeah.
Do you know the pink looks really good on you?
Does it dude?
Real men wear pink.
I know.
Cameron does.
You look,
it looks actually really flattering on your skin tone.
Pretty Blue Eyes.
Maybe there's a new thing coming that I'm going to tell you later.
Okay.
Hey,
did I,
uh,
did you read that thing that,
um,
burden Ernie from sesame street?
Did you hear that?
Think that like that were,
I'm new here or something.
Do you think that I don't work
here?
I don't know.
Oh,
okay.
Well,
I mean,
I'd be happy to do that.
that's what friends are for,
aren't they okay with their friends?
His nose is back on,
right?
Okay,
sure.
We know we done
hold on.
Can,
I don't think that's quite all right.
I look at that.
Look at that.
Bird will tell the folks what a actually happened this past.
So it,
it came to one of the writers,
I believe,
of sesame street,
said that burden Ernie are in fact a gay couple.
And that yes,
everybody's suspicions for years that they were gay.
Well,
he said that he wrote on the show for years and he said that he always based
writing them on his own relationship with his partner.
Oh,
I didn't even know that.
That's like a,
I used to always think he goes,
I just thought of them the way I thought of myself and my partner.
And then sesame street came out and was like,
no,
like,
it's not.
Yeah,
they were like,
they're just friends.
Yeah.
But I don't know.
This is the guy who he's,
he obviously is saying as somebody who was writing week to week on this show.
Yeah.
That's how I envision it.
That's how he wrote for them.
So and so unconsciously or whatever.
They are gay.
Um,
but if you see Burton or Ernie,
they sleep in the same room,
but in separate beds,
like in 1950s couple yeah.
Like Lucy and Ricky,
like they're kind of like a chase to gay couple.
It's Kinda cute.
Here's a,
some more super cute cliff's.
Let me know if you think this is gay.
Hey,
Ernie.
Lottery bird weighed 'em man at Ernie.
You are not going to cut my hand.
Rd.
I assure you know what you're doing.
We bought a bird on your shoulder.
We're pretty close.
We're pretty.
Clip,
clip,
clip.
Just a haircut like a month from my head
the whole month.
What are you gonna do about it?
Oh Wow.
I have just the thing for you.
Just a second.
Oh my hair.
What's it going to do?
There you go.
Bird.
What is that?
A book up.
What?
Make my hair grow faster.
No,
but it'll give you something to do while you're waiting.
Hmm.
Yeah.
That doesn't feel gay.
Not at all.
I don't know.
These aren't gay examples at all and I don't know why they're in here.
What about this one?
They're in bed.
Boy,
you thirsty?
That's gay.
Okay.
Am I thirsty?
Yes.
Oh,
if you're so thirsty,
why don't you just get up and get yourself a glass of water?
Huh?
Well,
because burned.
I'm so tired.
I don't know.
The only thing I am more than tired is thirsty,
thirsty,
worry.
They taste good.
Gee,
what am I
thirsty?
Yes sir.
So cute.
I do love them so much.
You don't see Bernie that much?
No you don't.
You don't really see them that one.
Cause we watch it
and uh,
our kid likes super Grover 2.0 yeah.
Yeah.
Thank you.
That's good.
They're adorable.
I mean these,
these,
uh,
examples did not really lead me to think that I was anything gay.
No,
I feel like,
okay,
so there's a sense of mystery book we have and they,
they do shout outs to them being gay.
I think like for instance,
there's like a panel the open and it's like Bert and Ernie in the closet burden
or any out of that closet one that is the funniest.
I mean,
do they have to know that that's a nod to and being gay for the parents?
I think,
yeah.
It's always in the closet.
Like Ernies clothes are in the closet.
Burt's in the closet.
They do it all the time.
Yeah.
I see.
I,
maybe I'm reading into it,
but,
oh,
um,
did you see that the member,
we showcased those guys that had the,
uh,
that the put up the picture of Mcdonald's?
Yes.
Mcdonald's found out.
I read that they gave him $25,000.
Yeah.
I guess is advertising fees.
I thought it was a good thing.
Yeah.
That's super cool.
Yeah,
it's um,
it's pretty cool.
They,
uh,
they,
I think they went on Ellen and Ellen.
So for those of you don't remember,
we've featured,
we showed the clip.
These Asian kids notice that there were no portrayals of Asian people happily
eating McDonald's,
buster local Mcdonald logo on.
So they took their own photos and they put on a poster that looked identical to
the other ones that Mcdonald's had and they just slipped it in there and they
made a video they put on youtube and Mcdonald's didn't notice for like weeks and
weeks until it went viral.
Hilarious.
So now they found out and they gave these kids 25 grand,
which is awesome.
That's a good move on their part if you want to see this.
A crybaby.
Yeah.
Complaining about,
watch.
Oh,
here,
hold on,
hold on.
I was flying from the east coast to the west coast as going back to my feet.
I pass by a young man who was looking at porn on it.
Oh No,
no.
Time to cry.
I went to a local university for college.
Are there is this thing that we started doing where we would go to a,
like an adult store and pick out like the cheesiest porn film,
take it back to the dorm and it was like,
uh,
like a judging competition.
Okay.
So yeah,
I eat the ass and pussy all the time.
I got nothing.
We used to do that too in college.
My friends and I would watch like,
but sex porn,
like did gay dudes and laugh and stuff.
We can only watch it for like five minutes before you're thoroughly grossed out.
Michelle,
we have a career off of what she's talking about.
Oh,
I know what,
what's the problem?
I honestly don't know what the problem is,
right or wrong,
doing what she did,
judging the,
these people doing it.
I think watching
it was so wrong and I knew it and I did it.
Stop watching it or being a part of that.
I don't want to be other,
she's sit there.
It's like there's a bible and crosses all around her.
I think she had something traumatic happen.
Oh
sure.
I look back and I think if only your voice was stronger.
If only you could have said something,
what would you have said to them?
Two.
You guys want to all fuck right now.
Wait till it to the guy on the plane watching porn.
No,
no,
they just talk about in college when they rented the video.
What the fuck is a problem here?
I take that into,
you know that the situation of the young man on the flight,
because even like 36,000 feet in the air,
he couldn't get away from these images.
Oh,
I don't know.
I don't think it's an addiction so much is poor.
Poor manners.
You know,
you don't watch porn on a plane.
Yeah.
That,
that is a problem here.
That is poor manners.
That is,
I,
you know,
it's,
it's just human.
Humans have needs and masturbation is one of those needs,
right?
It's neither here nor there.
Yeah,
it's whatever,
man.
This is cry baby being about that fucking nonsense.
I know you'd like to fuck my big black hair.
All of these things are just like rushing over me like until you really see what
I thought I saw it.
I sat down,
I just started praying like,
God,
what do I do?
Should I even do anything?
You know?
Like,
is this my responsibility?
Oh boy,
you're fucking short.
Can Sag it,
man.
I tell you though,
the big reason I'm not into religion is this nonsense.
Like this is the worst.
Why is sex have to be demonized?
I don't understand is the worst I have.
Why I so push back on this shit so hard now because that was raised in this kind
of culture that I cannot help but laugh and mock this kind of nonsense.
I mean,
and as I was praying,
I really began to feel protective over him,
over the nail kit.
Check it off.
You are God's beloved and most cherished son.
That's our,
we'll have you suck his dick.
Do you,
but do you think God is like looking down at the master baders and keeping a
list of who's who of WHO's fucking who of course wrong way.
And as he was coming off the plane,
he looked like he was lost.
And so I took that as my opportunity.
If you're looking for baggage claim and he said,
no,
I'm going on to another flight.
And I said,
okay,
hey listen,
I have something to give you.
And now I take my card.
And he took it and kind of just looked at me and quizzes Dively and just looked
at my card and I said,
there's some websites and some things on there that I really think would be
beneficial to you.
Oh my God.
To look at it now you can put it in your backpack,
but at some point it'd be great if you look at it and I just want you to know
that you are so much more.
Oh my God,
I just take my fucking,
who the fuck are you to judge this guy jerking it on a plane?
Well,
that's the thing is that there's always this like this a line that comes out of
these people about Joe.
Only God can judge and they're judged.
That's what I'm saying.
It's so hypocritical.
It's always like,
only leave judgment to God,
but by the way,
let me ruin your flight today.
They're horrible.
Is there anything worse than getting one of those fucking pamphlets stuck in
your,
you know,
your front yard somewhere in your daily work?
They came yesterday.
No,
I know they always continent.
Yesterday I was trying to take a fucking nap and I heard uh,
hey,
wait,
I want to discuss this prayer.
I was like,
no,
get the fuck out of here.
What's your prayers
listen and all the problems.
Do you think God's got time to worry about who's touching themselves?
I don't know.
I mean he's,
he definitely has a busy schedule.
Yeah.
There's just so many things about how,
how much does eyes probably dart when he's like,
like of his secretary is like,
we've got to cover a masturbatory right now.
Wow.
Shit that's going on everywhere.
And I like,
yeah.
And I'm keeping records of everyone.
So you can punish them later.
Ah,
here we go.
Yeah.
Oh there's so bad.
So many too.
And what about all the people?
The premarital fuckers too?
Yeah.
On a full time Gig for guy.
I mean God just has nothing but just time to yell at these nuts busting
everywhere and God's got to worry about every Jizz,
every piece of jazz.
It's a,
it's a private,
it's a busy world.
Kind of wonder where the com is
so weird.
Did you see this?
A God doesn't care about come.
No,
I don't think he does.
I think I read a book title.
God doesn't care about come once.
I don't think he's into it.
He's not interested in where,
how you come?
I don't think so.
No,
I think so.
Either what you eat.
That one I never understood either.
God is like pork is terrible.
I hate pork.
If you loved me,
you would never eat bacon there.
Do Fish on Fridays guys.
Well,
like if you actually take the time to look up the reasons why certain cultures
don't eat certain foods,
it's always tied to like the time,
like when food couldn't be preserved,
no refrigeration.
Oh,
that's why.
And then they're like,
yeah,
you know,
thousand years have gone by,
but we're just going to stick to it.
You know what,
why?
Because there's a book.
Okay.
Yeah,
I get it.
Isn't it interesting too,
like with homosexuality,
that was so good.
What were you going to feel?
So yeah,
they,
the Greeks were the biggest,
but fuckers and kid fuckers love to fuck.
They loved it.
They had fuck everybody.
And you know,
the Christians came along and we're like,
no,
but they,
you know,
they've been fucking for centuries people.
Yeah.
And now you're going to be like,
it's wrong.
Okay.
No,
but fucking fucking kids forever.
We've been doing it forever.
I have come all over my face.
Yeah.
I mean the kid fucking,
I don't condone,
but no,
you shouldn't.
The Butt fucking,
who cares?
I think we finally,
I think it actually took the last 25 years and people are Kinda like,
all right,
so bud fuckers,
all right.
I mean it's been a problem for a hundred centuries,
but now they're like,
they're like,
okay,
you guys get above a,
you guys are gonna do this real kiss.
A real cause.
I was both fucking my mom.
It's funny you said that.
Here's a real kiss.
It's right there.
It was a real,
because it's just like the gays.
They fucking the butt to Oh fuck.
Ah.
You see this guy,
um,
that passed out had an overdose?
No.
What they tried to do for him on the street,
this is ridiculous.
Oh no
show.
This dude is oh deed on the side of the,
on the sidewalk and this guy is pouring milk.
Oh dear.
And people are like,
he doesn't need milk.
He needs a God damn ambulance.
You know?
He's like,
he's,
wait,
what are we,
what are you doing with these ambulance?
He needs an ambulance right now.
Oh,
he's fucking overdose.
Oh my God.
Who's overdosing?
I called nine one one call nine one one three.
She
let her get some time to breathe.
Take a minute to get out and give it some time.
Oh,
the milk worked?
No,
he don't need no dude,
dude.
He just almost fucking die dude.
Who just fucking saved your life.
The milk?
Yeah.
Milk works every time.
When you d check this out?
Yeah.
Is He gonna Barf?
He just saved your fucking dude.
What the fuck?
He just fucking mind.
I'm great fall.
I don't know.
That felt kind of contrived to me.
Oh,
that guy looks like he did Odie.
They all look like shit,
but I still think it was a bit,
yeah.
Well I saw the low.
That's too bad.
Pre run down here.
I think it's,
I think it's okay.
It was choreographed.
You look so cute in that pink beanie.
I'm all about the pink hat life.
Can I looks good.
Um,
do you think orange is my new color?
Orange is the new pink.
I know.
Yeah.
No,
it does look good.
Actually.
Your whole gear looks fresh.
The fresh dude.
Yeah,
it looks real fresh.
Okay.
Um,
our guests will be here shortly.
Do you want to take a quick break?
It's get a goddamn snack.
All right.
And we'll be right with
two guests.
Some nasty,
nasty.
All right,
we're back.
And um,
look,
we did what you said.
We recovered in it.
You said this was an even exchange.
So what you told me,
put the fucking gear on.
And so here we did it.
All right.
They're all in on the teddy fresh react to,
I said,
listen,
if you don't go head to toe over the top and a teddy fresh,
I'm not coming on the show.
It's all I'm wearing from.
It's so comfortable.
I love the colors.
I never wear color on the show.
I'm always wearing black.
So this is very good.
Honestly,
I think doe and over the shoulder style,
like the young black kids are doing.
No white kids are doing it.
Are they?
Well,
that's what happens.
They'll do it first and then we go,
hey,
that looks good.
I know that's a really natural look for you.
I'm going to be seeing you in a lot of Photoshop.
Yeah.
Um,
no,
I actually love your gear.
I told you that when I first met you guys,
thank you for coming over.
Thank you guys for inviting us.
I was teased because I think after I did your podcast and I talked about it on
this one,
I said I was with a Etha.
I didn't say Ethan and a lot of people make fun of me.
Ether ether.
I think I was thinking of he la and then I stopped saying it.
You know what I mean?
I confused the two names.
You didn't think my name was Ethan.
I didn't think it was Ethan.
It just came out.
That thing that came out that way because nobody's named Isa.
That's not a name combination of the two.
I just wanted to come out and say that.
I know your name is Ethan.
Oh yeah,
sure.
Thank you for clarifying that because I was a lot of people.
We've been talking about that.
Yeah,
the whole Etha thing and you're worked up about a lot of people then.
Yeah.
Thank you for clarifying.
So just everybody knows it's ether with an end.
Eli Eli,
I've been saying with a hard age and you can say it both ways,
it's fine.
No,
you're not a door.
Yeah.
Well
Doug Betsey's jumping all over.
So Isla his name,
it's like simple but also the hardest thing to say in the world for an American.
Oh yeah.
Like when I first met her in Israel,
it was just like Isla,
like she puts a little twist on it like and I'm like,
oh my God,
how do I say that?
But then when you realize it's just h I l a [inaudible] it's like,
oh it's just Ila.
It's a pretty nice,
I am so excited to me.
Another couple in the comedy podcasting world and you guys like each other.
He love each other.
Most days.
I was telling Ethan that it's really inspiring to see you guys cause you both.
You both have your own career and kids and dogs.
You're normal.
You're like cool people.
How you guys are amazing.
You guys are,
there's two married news teams and the tries to,
I know what happens now.
No,
you guys are seriously amazing.
Like,
yeah,
I love,
I love everything about you guys.
You know what I love most about you guys,
um,
is your love of Brown talk.
That's Ralph town.
That is all he knows all him.
I participate.
I have no problem with it.
He brought it into the table.
What I love about Brown town is why I elected visit there so frequently is that
it's this secret world and not so secret in our lives,
but in most people's lives,
people have their own techniques.
They come from the front,
they come from the back,
they come from the side they use,
but days they have baby wipes.
There's a whole wealth of knowledge that we as a society are not building upon.
We write books about science,
about math,
about psychology,
hobbies of all sorts and sizes.
But there's no collective knowledge about Brown.
And I think that some people do it wrong.
Have you been talking to my dad?
This is verbatim.
It has he owned this?
Yes.
Well you've runs in your family.
That's special.
I know.
But he's always like,
well,
people don't talk about it.
So
it's funny too.
It funny,
you know,
I,
I like to say the first time I ever got fingers moving,
my finger slipped through the toilet paper.
So it goes all the way back to the first time I figured my own asshole.
And here's the thing,
it,
it's like,
look,
everybody farts,
everybody makes Dukie right.
And people feel weird about it,
but it happens.
And the truth is it is something that you should kind of talk about more.
And it is funny.
It is funny to see,
they know that all of us,
no matter what you look like,
make big,
nasty,
measurable and it's Smelly,
awful.
And it hurts.
My Dad love it.
I was telling him that one time,
I was like,
keep wiping.
You know,
he's keep wiping and what's going on?
He's like,
you need to wipe down buddy,
because you're watching.
Oh,
wipe up.
He was telling me that I'm wiping up too much wiped down.
Don't,
don't go in his much.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Like don asks too many questions.
That's about it.
Yeah,
that's right.
You know,
one from a parks and recreation where he says it's like wiping up marker.
Yeah.
It's called the but stamp or the neverending wipe.
We call it that or leaky,
but sometimes I have a problem because I cannot,
I can't leave it.
I need to run the marker dry.
I'm not what kind of guy that it's like,
hey,
it's just one of those days so I gotta get in there.
I'm scooping,
I'm Robyn,
I'm doing whatever it takes because,
and frankly I don't understand these anecdotes.
You hear about these guys that have shits stains on their underwear.
That's people are unacceptable,
man.
They really are the guys.
The person was like,
well that's enough for today.
We can always,
ah,
I'll get home and I'll wash them.
But you got shit literal shit in your underwear.
What the fuck?
I won't even scratch my back like my ass hole itchy asked.
I'll do it over the underwear over and I ever do.
I'm so paranoid about a real itchy asshole having chocolate on there.
I will go to a bathroom to get toilet paper to scratch my,
well if my app,
okay,
well if my asshole is ever that itchy,
yeah,
yeah.
I'll assume that.
Maybe I didn't wipe it off.
That's my first assumption.
That's why I'll go get toilet paper and see what's going on.
There's usually a little residue,
but nothing too bad.
Yeah.
You guys got me thinking about it because you're right.
When it's the marker scenario,
like who's that lazy person that's like,
I'm good.
Whatever.
Whatever happens today.
Some guy,
that's crazy.
It's insane.
People also don't look up the,
they don't look at the paper.
Good point.
People are,
of course,
every time.
Look,
every time I look on the first one,
it's like,
you know their shit though.
I look,
I look at the paper every time.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but you don't look at the bull.
You said,
I never look at the bowl.
I got to see it all the way through.
I already know.
I know.
It's like blah,
blah.
My,
I'm like looking at are you interested?
Not really.
There's a lot of information about,
yeah,
what's going on.
I know.
I feel like I can feel it though.
I can feel the information.
I know.
You're right.
I really do.
You know,
wonder.
There's just so much.
That's just so much to talk about.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
like women,
they all talk about their periods.
They share information,
techniques,
but we all shit,
all of all of us this room,
you know what I'm saying?
And so Anders all binaries,
right?
There's no argument about,
um,
oh,
I'm not,
I don't identify as this gender.
You still shit.
So we're not debating that.
Right.
So I just,
I don't understand the,
the lack of dialogue about it.
So what old blind people do.
Oh,
okay.
We've
talked about that on this show.
Do they smell it and know what was the answer?
They actually,
somebody actually answered us like they,
they sense it.
Right?
They have that daredevil level of now they got
squishy that toilet paper bills.
They get a sense for it.
Yeah.
Like what it was.
They stay sense.
The resistance of the paper,
how it moves.
That's not accurate.
It's of coil.
It's not,
they want their a blind people are walking around with Shitty assholes.
But that's fine.
They go fast.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They get a pass.
But what is that?
Is there a feedback from my phone?
I've got,
oh,
should we turn it all the way to,
there you go.
That's why you,
where should I move it away?
Maybe.
Maybe I'll throw number.
Here's my worry for you.
So,
okay.
You're telling me that you,
when you have a marker kind of day,
you don't have,
you guys don't have the days yet.
No.
So what are you doing?
Yeah,
you were talking about and that's during junior forces.
Well,
it's a,
I mean you're about making the leap though,
right?
Yes.
I have some,
I have some issues with a buddy.
Hey,
I was in Canada recently and to my great surprise,
they had these wonderful Japanese toilets.
Leaky.
This was in Quebec and Montreal.
What'd I say?
That's the state.
So it's a,
yeah,
in Montreal.
And they had the whole thing with the heated seat and the water at squirts it
right at your asshole.
And there's all the different pressure settings.
It's got the whole,
it's got the whole works.
It even if you can,
my language,
it has a front squirt,
which I was like,
oh,
what the fuck is that?
And I checked score to by taint.
Yeah,
it feels good.
That was interesting.
I was just kinda like moving all over the place is that I was like,
Oh shit,
the Vaginas Kinda,
they're not that write up.
It's not that far from the asshole because it's basically like just a very,
the front load.
It was very close to the back.
Well see and that's why wiping properly so important and they tell you you can't
go back to front,
front to back is it's very,
you know,
so is it not an issue that if you're squirting,
you're gonna splash some shit water.
The problem I had with it was that I was squirting and I was squirting and water
was running down my balls.
Why
not have that?
I mean every time.
Yeah.
But the other thing I do avoid that if you keep that water running eventually
he's just beautiful,
clean water.
So I think you might have some browns splatter,
but that water is going to keep hearing this.
He's getting shit on his balls.
Hello?
What's new?
I mean that's my man there.
Shit everywhere.
There's hair everywhere to look at scrum and I won't do it because that's the,
the,
it's kind of just that general area.
I feel like she wants to Tang.
Yeah,
Tang be whole.
All of it.
She won't do it.
You ask no way.
She's a good girl.
I would never,
I would nasty girls eat scrum thing is my asshole.
The thing is like if you're nasty as hell.
Thompson.
Anyways,
Ethan and I were talking and I were talking I think is my asshole's not was
never meant to be licked.
Right.
Don't like that either.
A warning zone gusting.
Yeah.
I have a feeling we,
I mean looking at you,
I think we have the same
similar issues.
Yeah.
Harry and hot cause his bottles Harry and hot.
My thought always bold my but always has heat coming off of it.
It could be sub arctic weather and like put your hand.
You'd be like,
oh my hands a friend.
This guy.
Just always,
why you're such an oven.
I don't know that asks oven.
I know.
It's just like welcoming for a tongue.
It's like he's got a hung out there
saying put your mouth down here lady.
It's nice.
Yeah.
Have you seen as be hall,
uh,
how long have you two been together now?
What's the last time I saw it?
I haven't seen my own asshole since I was like 13.
I was like,
what am I an asshole look like it doesn't look nice.
Well you look once in your life that God don't need to do that.
Yeah.
I remember I spread my cheeks to a friend in middle school.
Really?
What was the context?
It was like,
it was just like sleep over stuff and I just spread my cheeks to him and he
goes,
Jesus.
And uh,
and it was Peter and he goes,
you should hair.
Yeah.
And I was like,
it was amazing.
And I wasn't as Harry then,
so I was like,
did you feel like you understood something new about yourself in that moment?
He said it.
I knew that it was like not something to show a girl.
Right.
You know,
because he was like
14 years different.
That's love.
I love that
we show them one day when you show them,
whoa,
no,
like he does this.
Okay,
so we'll be like them one day.
Okay.
So we'll be playing around in the rumor and he does this like slutty stripper
girl move where he turns,
he turns his back to me and then he like bends over and then he slaps his ass.
He like Shimmies is hands down the back of his legs and some tops.
That's pretty hot.
Moving a little bit.
I wanted to offer you guys and then you see his asshole.
Sometimes I'll pull his pants down and then he'll spread it because as I run my
hands down the back of my legs,
I'll pull my shorts with it.
Like here's a little treat for you.
I'll just show everything.
Does that do anything for you?
Not as gross as Tom is with me.
Am I right?
Do you guys okay?
I'm gonna ask you this.
Do you poop with the doors open?
Are we closed door?
Family?
It happened was when the doors open,
sometimes it's,
I'm not going to go full door open,
but like crack a jar.
So that's one that we don't do our boundary,
really talk about it here,
but door closed,
door closed just this morning.
You look Claude,
the fucking toilet in the room.
We exercise like literally like her shit was so massive.
I mean I don't clog toilet and so that was just,
we just exercise next to Ilissa a shitty clogged toilet.
But what are you going to do to fix that?
Are you going to call us?
Actually Ethan told me that it was fixed while I,
well he was like,
we gotta get,
we gotta get a plunger.
And I was like,
just give it a minute and she leaves the room and then you hear inevitably
though
the earth took it back.
Wow.
You got lucky then.
Yeah.
So is he not as grows with you as Tom is with me,
would you say are yeah,
I think so.
Probably.
Sounds like I walk around naked and I feel like that's gross enough.
I see myself in the mirror and I'm like,
fuck,
I can only do it for a moment.
I'm so ashamed of my,
I can only like flash it and be like,
I got to cover this.
Right.
Yeah.
I tried to Ethan and will make himself little growth third than he needs to like
band and show me the fold.
Well are you,
are you ever do this?
Like you just,
your back here,
bend over and when you're naked and you see it like resting on your legs,
the one,
it's like an,
it's like an appendage.
Yeah.
And it restricts your breathing.
It just restricts your breathing.
If you sit for you like,
oh,
why can't I breathe as well?
Cause my stomach,
you know,
pressing up on my lungs.
The last time I went on a series of diet was,
it was,
I had this moment I was tying my shoe and I couldn't breathe.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
I was like,
you're winded.
No,
I was not.
It's not that I was exhausted.
I,
there was so much pressure on my lungs,
I couldn't literally breathe.
And that was like warning signs.
Yeah.
That's when I lost like 15 pounds.
Oh.
How'd you do it?
What was your I just didn't eat.
Yeah.
That's the only way to lose weight.
You know,
my favorite is when I leave up the stairs and I,
you know,
when you're jumping up and you can feel your fat tire at the same time,
that's kind of special,
so yeah.
Yeah.
That is special.
I agree.
She's not part of this conversation.
The offer I was going to make you guys,
by the way,
and this is like I'm hooking you up.
Yeah.
Really?
You want me to model for the Teddy fresh line?
You are.
I'm just going to take stills from this whole,
yeah,
I'm a,
I'm actually a really good model.
Really?
Yeah.
Can I get an asshole shot?
I'll give you asshole shot.
I can with the fanny pack over your panties.
Grantees.
I know how to do wires.
Looks fierce.
Absolutely.
I've had like a patented head head twists.
Ready?
Go ahead.
Oh,
right here.
Oh.
Have you seen Tyra banks do her walk?
Oh,
sorry.
So amazing on Instagram.
Tyra is like,
I love,
she's so insane and I find her hilarious.
Have you seen the Vaseline clip?
No.
Oh,
we watched stuff.
Oh yeah,
sure did.
She put on her teeth?
Nope.
Oh,
you'll never mind breed.
So this clip you want me?
Never guess.
So let me set this up and just tell you that this is not a parody.
K.
Okay.
This is honest to God.
Real tight.
So tight.
Just on Youtube.
Tyra banks a Vaseline.
Vaseline giveaway.
I see it.
Yeah,
Just pull this up.
Bob it up there.
It's short and it's sweet and it's one of my favorite clips on.
Okay.
Okay,
let's,
let's check this out.
She's crazy shit.
All right,
here we go.
I'm about to reveal my beg is beauty.
Okay.
Anything cream meaning I and anything.
All right.
And during the break we had some hockey play.
The brought out these very special boxes to our studio audience and inside the
boxes is my super duper no fell.
Getting,
saving high in anything.
Cry.
Hey,
I want you to open them together.
Are you ready?
Yeah.
So weird.
What is it?
What are they all freak out about?
Is it a car
or is it a travel size bottle of
mocking Oprah?
How Oprah would do that.
It's not a joke I sweat about.
It's like it's done premium.
Bassa
she got directions on the box.
It's got Ryan stuff.
She stayed,
continues on.
She has like,
she starts like seizuring and the,
but I love,
there's so crazy.
Well,
we've been following her.
I follow her on Instagram and she's,
I guess on America's got talent right now she's hosting or something
and like her old talent is walking,
which I guess it's like a,
you know,
models that's a fucking talent duty.
But she's like,
nobody walks like me.
I'm fierce.
So Tom and I been practicing our fierce model walk.
Yeah.
It's,
it's a,
it's a huge deal.
And Hi.
Yay.
It's uh,
it's really fair.
The next top model or did you guys ever watch that horse horse?
Best show ever.
But she,
uh,
um,
fairs the,
well this is classic.
Uh,
oh,
a little kept.
They're like,
hey,
it's the foot in front of the foot.
Yeah.
Like,
dude,
you're prancing like a pony.
But I feel like models don't do this today.
I know,
right?
It was like yesterday.
It's like cheesy now.
That was how to cut when I was,
when I was like fashion.
When I first started going through puberty,
she was like popular fuck she had is your jam.
She had it yet.
You rubbed a few out to her bro.
Bro.
I felt I squirted in many cups.
Yeah.
By the way,
for context.
Yeah.
I don't actually collect my semen.
I'm just making a joke about testing my semen for sure to get you the pregnant.
But now she's just a bit of a,
I mean,
she still looks good.
She loves sharing.
Has been around forever.
Those,
uh,
those supermodels that we grew up with,
they basically all look amazing story.
That's true.
Genetic phenotypes.
You know Christy Brown,
you know what it is.
Yeah.
Ireland.
Cindy Crawford,
Turlington coping.
It is Vaseline and it's the fucking best.
Where do I get that shit?
Fuck.
That's her beauty secret.
That was so bizarre.
He's got a best friend here.
That's Fifo.
His mouth smells really bad.
Sorry.
Thank you Brett.
He's an old dude.
Hey Buddy.
His mouth stinks.
So,
so Germany has this program,
do you know where disabled people can legally find someone to help make them
come?
I think a state head of the gay.
I know,
right?
Like does that include me?
Whoa.
Can I say
let's enjoy it.
Let's say I actually,
why I want to enjoy this video.
Okay.
All right.
Is
one that we all have inside of us.
Sexual energy means we surely realize the reason why sexual assistance is so
necessary.
Very.
I'm reading because I didn't realize this is all Alphas.
Well why not just get a prostitute though?
I guess.
I think they are.
They are like state sponsored.
Hmm.
Prostitutes specifically for the disabled Holzman's that's,
that honestly is a tender beautiful thing.
It is for a state,
for an actual government organization.
Like be like these guys.
They need someone to touch their dick.
Yeah.
As much as any,
any of us more maybe.
Sure.
I mean I might try to be disabled if she's one I have,
she the one that's,
she's getting to.
What if one of these,
what if he's like,
well you look my asshole.
Like,
I didn't even look.
My husband died.
She's like,
I can't come.
She's not the check that comes to your house.
No way,
dude.
I Dunno.
She's looking at me like she comes to the house and Yup.
That's the lady dude.
That guy's having the time.
It was
for those of you just listening.
It's like,
wait,
who's The handicapped there?
Oh,
right.
Well there was like,
I just didn't know who was,
who was getting the benefit.
It's the guy,
the guy's getting the benefit.
I'd fuck that guy.
What's wrong with them?
I don't know his legs.
Yeah.
I'm having like a weird thing where I did,
it looks like a her legs.
It doesn't yet.
The photograph kneeled on the floor though.
Okay.
You see her legs?
Yeah.
Going on in the side there.
I like,
I don't know that the state should sponsor it,
but it is.
Well,
they're basically telling their citizens,
you need to come.
You're telling them don't keep it all in,
not too handicapped to come.
It's like a,
it's a,
it's sex welfare.
How progressive that is.
Progressive as it gets.
It's pretty great.
I'll show you
who's coming right now.
That's just a care
carefully screened.
You better make them currently trained.
They're trained to provide,
it's just a blonde guy on the street.
I,
let's cut to the chase though.
He get laid on his own.
I don't think that being blind really is that much of a hindrance of getting on?
I don't think so either,
but I would,
I would take good lay into it.
If I was in Germany I'd be like,
I can't see any,
oh that's he is the,
he's saying I see her twice a month learning different sexual positions.
I'm young,
I'm satisfied.
I'm not in love with Laca.
I'm looking for a girlfriend.
Okay.
He's learning all those things to do.
That's cool.
Yeah.
That's quite a gig though,
man.
I ask a question.
Yeah.
Cause there's like diseases that make like old people look like children.
Pejorative.
Pretoria.
Do you fuck like that's like as the sex worker you have to fuck.
Yeah.
Like it's a person that looks like a kid.
Oh,
that'd be tough.
Did they really look like a kid though?
Like whoa,
creepy old,
creepy,
old case.
Physically,
I don't know.
Well this kind of reminded,
I know this brings me back to our opening clip was this guy who faked being
disabled so that um,
caretakers would change his diaper and bathe him.
Why didn't he got,
he got arrested.
Whoa.
That's like,
it seems like he was actually basically wanting,
it was just enjoying.
Yes.
Right.
Yeah.
So what he was doing was he put in,
um,
he signed on to a service online,
said that he was the character.
He pretended to be a woman named Amy said that had a,
a client that needed bathing and changing and then hired people.
But he was the one doing the whole time and then pretended to be disabled and
then somebody,
yeah,
wait,
but this would take away was actually like supportive of,
of his,
and then I realized he's pretty criminal.
It doesn't,
this takeaway sex workers work.
I mean it's,
it's sex work illegal in Germany.
No problem.
Yeah,
they're probably the same people.
Oh,
they're getting hooked up everyone.
Okay.
Gotcha.
Hookers getting paid by member.
Yoshi said his favorite place was a Frankfurt or something to go for his.
One of our friends only sees hookers.
Oh really?
International.
And he saves money like he'll do,
he does medical testing on his own body,
like who signs up for those things?
Just might kill you.
This might give you a Parkinson's.
And he's like,
okay.
And then they pay out,
you know,
it's like five grand for weeks of staying there and Parkinson's.
Yeah.
I'm like,
so what are you doing now?
He's like,
well,
I got like five grand,
I'm going to go to Amsterdam.
I love,
yeah,
I miss living like that.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Kind of,
well not to that extent,
but I mean like when you get a hundred bucks and then you buy some beers and
sausages and you're fully content,
you know what I mean?
Sure.
That's that version of that.
Yeah.
Here's how marketing is he scamming anyone or I guess I just didn't understand
what's the crime?
This guy?
Yeah,
I was confused.
Really ever needed help.
And then what's the big deal if they're getting paid?
This was exactly my opinion is the government subsidizing.
I think it said,
boy,
she's chilling.
Chalkup pretended to have down syndrome,
so I didn't know.
Isn't there a look?
I mean I generally a look.
Yeah.
I feel like after I've seen the hospital and there's like,
you have a whole section of people and there's one person in on doing their
shift and then the every two hours they're like,
change everyone's diapers and then you realize like this is,
this has to be the worst job.
And they're like angels.
They are now.
That's why I was saying,
that's why when I heard that I was like,
that's evil
because these sweet people and getting actually I go like,
I mean,
what's he doing?
He's just like mechanic and he's enjoying himself,
but he is preying on somebody goodwill.
Yeah.
It's not in this put in the article I read there were like the caregiver's role.
Like he insisted on more thorough Washington generals.
They always had an erection for every bad.
Well that's just it.
Yeah.
That sounds like kind of like,
it's still honestly doesn't like just on the surface you're like,
yeah,
that's what he likes.
I mean it's icy.
I think you make a good point by the grace of God.
Walk these people on this planet and the sick fuck is making him rubbing.
Are we hearing this wrong?
By the way,
remember the baseball clip?
Are we hearing that wrong?
I don't know.
We should ask them.
Would you guys do
retarded?
I heard definitely something retarded.
Okay,
so we're not in,
we're not mishearing that.
Play it again.
Just want to make sure.
Retarded.
Yeah.
What else could he be?
Who holds is the guy's name?
Elder.
Cool.
Oh,
is retired.
Is he retired?
He does sound like you saying that right?
Yep.
Cool.
What else could it be?
I'm trying to rack my brain
retarded.
There's really no alternate explanation.
I just wanted to confirm when they confirm.
I heard,
that's what I heard.
Okay.
Right.
You heard something was our word really leaning into the r word?
I mean,
I'm just trying to understand what's happening.
I just,
I don't know.
Um,
here's what I want to ask you guys though.
So,
you know,
we've gotten to know you guys a little bit personally,
ultra fascinated because you know,
we come,
we come from the stand up performing world and honestly
the whole youtube of it all is almost foreign to us.
Right?
Like we always knew there's like youtube stars and stuff.
And then when you guys,
I was talking to you guys about how you got started.
You're like throwing up a video and at one point you said,
I think you said for two years you didn't have a thousand subscribers.
A year 10
they're just like two years to get,
I think a thousand subscribers.
Two years.
But that's like everybody's rise to you is different because it can happen.
You know,
there's people that will grow to start them
in those two years though.
Is this is just then a fun thing you're doing,
you're like,
yes,
we just enjoy ourselves.
Yeah.
There was nothing at stake.
There was no delusions of grandeur.
There was no expectation at all.
It was very much,
I mean our early videos are fucking so off the wall,
dude,
like complete like unwatchable.
So I'm not surprised at all that nobody watched them for that long.
There was,
there was quite frankly no reason to watch them.
Uh,
and they were also like where they,
uh,
just funny videos.
Yes.
Okay.
Attempt,
attempt at humor.
Yeah.
Gotcha.
I,
it was a lot of just trying to find my voice and my style
and you,
but you still are like,
this is just,
I do this for fun.
Right.
Very much.
Yeah.
I mean I wanted to,
um,
I want it to work in comedy.
I never,
I never thought that could be a performer.
I thought like,
Oh,
maybe I'll hold right for somebody.
But this was just my way of being like,
well I want to do comedy because I was,
I worked when we were in Israel for five years at a desk job and so I was five
years.
Yeah.
And Marketing.
Well I was going to school.
He was working,
I was working too.
But what was your desk?
What kind of job?
I was just a content manager,
cause I'm,
and you know,
I have a degree in English and writing.
So when you go to Israel,
that's actually like a marketable skill,
which was crazy because I was looking for a job for a year and then when I moved
to Israel all of a sudden I got a job,
like an actual real job.
So that was cool.
It's exciting for me at the time cause I didn't think that whatever,
you know,
whatever.
But so five years work in a job that I eventually wasn't satisfied because who
the fuck has satisfied with that work?
And just saying that I want to do comedy,
so let me do something about it.
So I just sat down or I'm going to start making some stupid videos on youtube.
And over the course of two years kind of found my voice.
And then I think we started getting more serious about it.
And when we've kind of found that different kinds of things that we thought were
working and were funny and like from the first two years and then from the third
year,
I think by the end of the third year we probably had a million subscribers.
So between year two or 3:00 AM I wrong?
When we left Israel,
when we moved here,
we had about a hundred thousand subscribers.
So at that point though,
let's
see,
I liked the tiers.
How long ago was that?
Three years ago.
That's why I basically,
we've been doing it professionally for
basically since we moved here.
So about three years.
You realize that you realize that's like that's a Nanosecond,
right?
Yeah.
That's crazy.
So wait on Youtube,
it felt like
time flies so fast on your toes.
It could happen to them over a month.
I'm like,
really?
That's happened many times.
Better to go your route.
Yeah,
it is.
Because these people,
they come and they go,
you don't want to be the rocket ship.
You want to be the steady,
steady climb at what point.
So at 100,000 subscribers you obviously know like,
well,
like people are digging what we're doing.
So then you go like,
we need to focus on it more.
Like we need to try and make this out.
We were very,
very focused on like the craft and the presentation and the packaging.
And um,
we were like perfectionists and we were just solely committed to creating like
one video a week.
That was like the best thing we could.
But,
and it was also finding,
cause we were both like,
we didn't know how to use the camera properly or sound or anything,
so everybody,
wait,
could we tried to make it better?
And we like starting from minus painful,
painful
through cute too that you guys see you did this all as a couple though too.
We made the channel,
um,
we made the channel together the first day.
Ella had a video,
our class and they,
it was one of the mandatory classes on the first year was video art and they
just gave us an assignment to make something.
And I,
I didn't want to be in it because I was so shy.
So I bought a camera on home and I was like,
do you want to do something?
And they record anything and that's how cool is that the first video that caused
the whole four years.
And,
um,
all the videos I showed them were really weird videos with Nathan.
What you get in that class?
What was the grade?
It was good.
It was,
I don't remember.
But you show up,
you get a good grade.
I was like a big Dorian.
Whoa.
All thanks to me for sure.
For sure.
For Ethan in your videos now the videos we made were very light,
like a Tim and Eric inspired and like lots of those guy nudity and just
disgusting,
like really off,
just like embarrassing.
And that me,
they didn't make it through Israel yet.
The fuck is wrong with you.
I think they thought we were trying to be like avant garde.
Yeah.
But not funny.
Definitely not funny.
So then when was it undeniable to you that this is actually a career?
The three years ago,
so I had a,
I had like a,
uh,
a job that was going really well and I'd worked there for a year and I had just
decided basically that I wanted to see this.
I don't,
I think I was probably making like $1,000 a month from youtube at the time.
It was not a lot,
but it was like,
hey,
that's a little fucking money.
Right.
So I quit.
I just said,
fuck it.
I'm going to quit my job and I'm a commit myself to doing this.
She was just because I want to give it a fair shot and um,
sorry to cut you up,
but this is the kind of real,
you have the kind of relationship with your parents where you tell them
something like that.
Like I'm quitting.
Yeah.
And they were like,
I mean they don't,
I remember my mom even with like,
really,
why are you sure you don't want to find another job before you quit your job?
And it's like,
no,
the point is to,
doesn't want to do that.
Well my mom was trying to get me to become a teacher.
Even,
even as recently as like,
like two years ago
they lived in Vegas and we,
when we first immigrated to the u s cause we've got yellow,
a green card after we got married.
And she's like,
are you sure you don't,
they have this great teacher program out here.
And,
and even at the time I was probably making like five,
$6,000 a month,
like doing like pretty good considering I was a youtube entertainer and that's a
great living.
But my,
I never really heated much advice from them.
So you take,
but at the time when you quit your thousand dollars a month revenue,
you really just focus on making these videos.
Yeah.
And then it just steadily paid off.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I never went back to work after that and it steadily paid off.
And I mean like Isla was like hand stitching these little,
we called them Jeff dumb fuck dolls cause I,
I'm obsessed with Jeff Dunham.
I think he's like fast.
The phenomenon of Jeff Dunham fascinates me.
Fucking venture look racist,
white trash ventriloquist that everybody loves.
Uh Huh.
And so I the label and
he literally wears like a shark tooth Pooka shell necklace.
Yes.
To this day he,
he also,
he also build,
he'll hand build a kit helicopter and then fly it,
you know,
like a,
basically a cheap helicopter.
He'll make one riot.
It's Kinda crazy too.
He will do daytime arena shows like high noon because that's,
that's just tough.
Right?
That's,
that's the toughest game.
But the kids will come.
The kids,
look I'm annual do like not just secondary markets like third or dairy.
We're talking like outside of the town,
outside of the town and sell out whenever you want.
I'll come.
I just,
he,
he's crazy.
But it's like nobody was like,
hold on,
this guy's a fucking ventriloquist.
Let's all stop and just think that this guy is actually doing comedy with
puppets right now.
Yeah.
You gotta love it.
He does.
So that thing,
fat but also his material fascinates me because it's all very racist.
It's got like the spicy Jalapeno.
Yeah.
It's just so that's when his career took off because you yeah.
Has been around a no,
he was around for a long time.
Do you want to know is what that was what made him take off?
Cause when nine 11 happened,
it made his career and he was just a puppeteer guy for you remember?
Or this cause I moved out here after nine 11 he was on last comic standing the
regional spot in like year two,
year three.
So he was still trying to get like bump,
like he had had a wave where he was successful and then it kind of faded a
little bit.
So he's on last comic standing.
This is year one or year two and I'm at the Melrose Improv for the taping.
So this is like the La spot and then they'll move on.
They,
they gave them strict instructions that like if you hit the two minute mark,
we will cut the sound.
Like we will pull,
the Mike will die and he was up there and ran the two minute mark and they cut
the sound.
And so he was still talking and they were like Jeff and they told him that he
was so pissed really in the back hallway.
He was yelling at someone.
And I'll tell you,
even that year you probably,
you were watching that,
like he was hoping for a break right here and it didn't happen.
It's when he took that Akhmed character,
I think it was Iraq war oh five mm.
And,
and so like when you know,
we're like the enemy is over there and started doing like,
uh,
you know,
we're like,
we're fucking with Iraq.
And started doing that character that it exploded for him.
Sinks below.
Say
it was nine 11 and it was like Ahmed remix.
It's like he got to use it.
You might be,
you might be right.
I know that she wasn't like that wasn't doing,
he wasn't doing arenas.
Some have theorized that Jeff Dunham was behind nine 11
actually all makes sense for his career.
That would be fucking amazing.
Jeff Dunham did not 11.
You hear it all here folks.
Yeah,
Bro.
So anyway,
um,
that was the craziest tangent,
but I had this Jeff Dunham fuck doll,
which was like this mutant aborted fetus and I will do this really fucked up
puppet shows.
It was,
I was also taking sculpture class.
I kept trying different snow.
I love this.
I tried to make in sculptures that I was telling like so why don't know,
I want it to make a doll of a girl sitting.
And it was a Miley set.
It was meant to mean Miley Cyrus.
It was based on the Miley Cyrus on the rocking bowl.
Oh yeah.
Music video.
So I it was just like a weird character.
Looks like an aborted fetus.
Yeah.
Well anyway,
the long story short is that people really love these things.
So either was hand stitching these and selling them and like we were going to
the post office every week and sending like dozens of these found stamps.com am
I right?
I wish I had stamps.com sponsored.
Not In Israel.
I have to stay in the line for like an hour ago.
Oh No,
no.
But we were,
yeah,
we were hustling.
We were hustling.
Love it.
You guys are such a great team because it's like the idea and then she would
execute the idea in an art school for people that just don't care who listen.
Uh,
only especially to the show like the,
you guys are like,
the videos are obviously you know this,
but they're legitimately really funny videos.
I mean you guys are making like really funny comedy stuff happened.
That's fine.
Um,
but also like I was,
um,
I remember when I first started checking you guys out online and I saw the
clothing,
I was like,
oh,
they have like everyone has merged,
they have merged.
And then I was like,
oh no,
they have a clothing line.
Things are actually designed here.
Well that's all Ila.
Yeah,
that's awesome.
First wanted to,
well,
either plan was always to become a designer and when I first moved to Israel,
she was in the middle of applying to become,
go to design school and they rejected her.
So she ended up going to art school instead.
But like,
um,
we came to a point.
Yeah,
yeah.
Fucking loser.
Hmm.
Anyway,
we came to a point where we were working very hard on our youtube channel and we
just thought like,
Hey,
we've got this opportunity.
We've got like the capital and we've gotten the fan base people who are
interested in,
you know,
consuming this product.
So we just thought it was a good opportunity for Eli to pursue.
Yeah.
Eighth really the one who pushed me to do it.
To do the fashion line.
Yeah.
Cause it was like why not?
I mean,
we have the money.
Well let's just try it.
While we was it scary though,
because I also feel like it's pretty scary.
I like the steps of like knowing what to do,
isn't it very like I don't know anything.
Yeah.
Well,
and that first you got to spend your own money.
Sure.
And commit to it,
you know,
and you just see money going out.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's okay.
I mean,
no,
it's fine.
But it was,
yeah,
I'm thinking we probably spent like a hundred thousand to start up with like
lawyers and Chloe and then getting the club,
paying for the clothing.
But the hardest part is fine.
Good,
good manufacturers.
It's very,
very difficult and everyone's very,
very tight.
It's,
it was like a black hole.
I mean,
we didn't know anything.
We were fortunate to meet some,
some guys with a small clothing company of their own reached out to see if we
want to clothing and we end up being like,
hey,
maybe these guys can help us out in the,
so they helped point us in the right direction,
which basically helped us start developing the first kind of collection that you
will put together.
That was really successful.
That's awesome.
How did that come about?
Um,
I,
I don't know,
just a name.
It rolls off.
It's just a name we call it.
It's embarrassing.
We call it,
we call each other ted,
teddy bear,
whatever it,
teddy bear.
Yeah.
You're cute little nickname for you,
us.
So that's awesome.
We are trying to think of something with like a logo and Oh,
this is a perfect time to ask this.
Then
we'll see if Isla,
is it actual FTT art.
Oh,
for God's sake.
So we appreciate that you love wore denim today on our show.
She knows so.
So we've been having this debate in recent weeks.
Okay.
I just want to see where you stand on this.
So let's say you're out and you come home and you get home and Ethan's leg,
Hey ted,
you're like,
Hey,
Teddi I love you.
And
He,
and he's like,
uh,
he's like,
ah,
I gotta tell you something.
And you're like,
did you forget to feed shredder?
And he's like,
no.
So I went to the bank and you know that guy who was up fucking Dick,
uh,
the parking attendant and you're like,
oh yeah,
that guy's such a dick.
He's like,
yeah.
So I saw him at trader Joe's and he was a dick there.
And anyway,
when I went back to my car,
his car was by the dumpster.
I stabbed him in the neck.
He's dead.
Um Huh.
Anyways,
the bodies in the trunk,
are you turning him in to the authorities?
Huh?
I mean,
it is your husband
notice she's thinking about it,
right?
Yeah.
Please.
Fire.
No.
Think about shredder.
Thinking about that your whole life,
everything you were used to.
It's,
that's a really tough question.
The guys are real Dick,
and you might have seen him be a dick.
I'll tell you what was my first response.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
I'm not doing it right.
That was my first ride or die for you.
Oh my God.
But it makes me think of,
it makes me wonder about myself,
like should I,
and was,
well,
the gut reaction,
what's the,
you live with the shame and the guilt,
but in that moment,
you know,
you torture yourself for the rest of eternity,
but you ride or die for your partner,
dude.
It's not even,
it's no question that you thought about that a little too long.
And I don't know.
Well,
I didn't actually kill somebody,
at least for the game.
Just say yes.
I mean,
I'm saying it's different.
These,
these checks are different.
So she is like,
yeah,
I'd course I'd fucking,
she's ready to try to,
you attorney may want to know why he's tear.
Here's why.
And I hear the fuck.
Hey,
now you're shaming me for taking too long.
Here's the caveat.
If he accidentally kill somebody,
oops,
I hit a bicyclist.
Okay,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna dig the ditch.
I'm the first one to find some core of what does it core core form hydrochloric
acid.
Chloric acid.
Fuck.
Yeah,
dude,
I'm right by accidental Detlef barriers.
However,
first degree lying in,
wait,
planning,
plotting somebody's murder and then not the guy you knew.
He's not the guy you thought he didn't.
You know?
That's right.
And also it means there's a switch that flipped.
Cause now he's acting on these impulses.
Poor impulse control,
thinking too much.
And,
and when is he going to turn that wrath on?
He's going to kill me on my children,
on my dogs,
please.
He's going to do this shit to us.
It's gotta be accidental.
Like,
Oh,
I just stabbed the guy to death.
Bang.
Yeah,
but there are different,
if you're it very realistically thank he's right in,
in reality that's probably,
see,
and that's where it,
but I'm thinking about it like in a love story.
Passionate.
That's where it should be.
Okay,
here's my mixers.
Like take your clothes off,
was thrown in the fire.
I got the,
I know that the place in Griffith Park,
we'll dump the body and I'm not,
and you're,
and you're like,
and I'm not even saying it hasn't happened before.
Absolutely not.
Wait Babe.
Okay,
go to you.
And I'd be like,
you don't have fucking sales clerk.
Yeah.
Down at the mall and Cinnabon.
She's been fucking eyeballing me.
Give me some shit.
Yeah.
Well,
the other day I waited for her in the parking lot and then I slit her Achilles
Tendon [inaudible] and then she collapsed the floor and then I fucking stab or
20 times and I put her in the trunk.
She's in the trunk right now.
Okay.
What do you say you're going to,
you're going to help me get rid of her 100% I wouldn't even think
twice.
Let's see that the thing that Tom,
Tom is assuming that you,
it's you,
your understanding
that,
you know,
that's what your guy,
you know what didn't do that,
so something's fucked up wrong and that he's saying that I'm,
they both on the same page.
You knew doing it.
Yeah.
Really your,
yeah.
You know what it makes me think about,
because I've been listening to stern a lot and he's been good
on the whole,
uh,
the Julie Chen Moon.
Yeah.
And so he,
and so there's a lot of debate about like,
okay,
we're talking about
murder.
Well,
this guy just,
you know,
raped a bunch of people.
Maybe not allegedly.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
A ledger that,
what do I know?
Yeah.
But,
uh,
if,
so like if you find out that Tom is a prolific writer,
oh my God.
I know pretty bad that I would tell somehow.
But,
but,
but that's true.
So the emotions of it are different.
If you look at it from Julie Chen Moonves.
Yeah.
It's like,
that's the guy,
you know,
but is it,
and what's true,
what's not right.
What's the what?
But in which case you've confessed that you've plotted somebody murder and then
you followed through.
Dude,
you're,
I'd have to assume you fucking lost your damn mind sign.
Yeah.
But I'm fine.
You're going to kill mine.
Let's go out to dinner when,
sorry about,
that's even scarier.
They are like,
what?
Of course you're not hungry.
Let's go get some shaky.
He's not a big deal for you.
That's way crazy.
I'm tired.
They had the,
I watched that documentary on Whitey Bulger,
you know,
the Boston,
uh,
he was,
he was 10,
10 most wanted for 20 years.
Right.
She,
James,
Whitey Bulger.
I love his name.
Yeah.
He ran and watch this kind of stuff.
No,
he ran the winner.
Normative.
Yeah,
me too.
The movie black mass,
easily black mass,
which everyone thought was about asshole was actually
about James bought Johnny Depp played him.
Anyway,
he was a ruthless Boston gangster and he ran what they called the winter hill
gang up there and they,
his uh,
one of his partners who's like,
was it government informed?
You know,
witness said that.
He was like,
yeah,
there's this thing about,
he goes,
I never saw Jimmy James Bulger.
Never saw Jimmy and such a good mood.
Then when he killed somebody,
he would just be in the best mood for,
can take a long nap and he would just be in the,
yeah,
the valve.
The tension.
The,
the guy who killed his partner,
one of his like partners stepdaughters and he was like,
we buried her in the basement.
He's like,
ah,
Jimmy wasn't the best move for days.
Say,
well no,
if killing people made you feel that good.
Yeah.
Battle.
I know what I mean.
It's not like to participate.
I think the thing is you got to learn to forget.
I need really suck that course.
I mean,
Shit,
Christina,
you need to learn to forgive.
And Christine,
Christine,
you learn to forgive and there's nobody better to tell you how to learn to
forgive.
Oh,
right.
Okay.
Oh,
what the fuck?
Thinking about forgiveness and did a deep journey for me because I've had to
look into the shadows of my own heart and understand how I've heard other people
and forgive myself,
she's naked in bed.
Yes.
Thank you.
Okay.
Why is this really everyone,
everyone in this family,
spouses different the Smith's,
right?
Yes,
yes.
Different lanes of wisdom for any
wrong accident might have committed or any pain that I might have
cause what did I just got a makeup on.
Her hair is done.
She just always
has,
um,
sort of insight into,
you know,
spiritual and psychological.
She says her son famously does as well.
He also shares thoughts.
Yeah.
Which is fine,
but maybe not naked in bed on Instagram
and forgiveness for myself.
Hmm.
It's such an unnecessary forgiveness or items.
Yeah.
Um,
I don't know about you,
but I'm obsessed with Instagram.
I like Instagram peoples.
It's a window into how people want to be perceived.
That's why I love it.
It's psychologically very fascinating to Instagram.
Sucks me in more.
I,
I'm on like a full social media detox.
Sure.
I have like even I have youtube,
Twitter and Instagram.
Not on my phone.
Wow.
It's uh,
just,
I just think it's good to just so you,
I don't be,
that guy is just a personal thing.
Yeah.
You were smart about in on my phone cause I feel like I don't have as much of a
problem with it.
I can control it more.
So if we need,
I think can do it on my spreadsheet.
That's how you do it.
It's called the,
it's self protection.
You know what I mean?
If there's something you need to know,
well that means I gotta go and show you all of these things.
Jesus.
I love watching the ship,
my internal emotional life terrain on the planet.
She flexing right now,
dad's home.
I know I have a Sahara desert within me.
That place where,
where are you?
She's in like a size that's probably her home bathroom
hasn't Arctica.
I have an Antarctica in me when I have hurts that run so deep that my compassion
and my understanding and my lungs is,
is frozen.
It looks like she's got Vaseline everywhere.
She looks great.
Why don't you let the record show to the audience?
I just opened up a bottle of water and I refreshed Isla and Ethan's glasses.
It's Ethan.
We did notice that.
Thank you Ethan.
Eila.
And I was so thoughtful.
That was a generous,
caring,
beautiful moment that only a mother could have been.
Yeah,
I don't water champion and a water change.
Um,
so because Christina thinks I am a violent psychopath,
I'm going to be taking this a psychopathy scale test.
So,
uh,
one of our listeners sent it in.
You say I watched too many murder shows so I won't go through the whole thing.
But basically I put a level of internet,
like on a scale of one to five,
one meaning there's no match,
five meaning a very good match.
You calculate the total score.
I'll do it after the show and we'll get back with my total score.
No,
but it says things like,
just to give the listeners an idea.
For instance,
number one,
success is based on survival of the fittest.
I am not concerned about the losers.
That would be a strong match.
Fine.
Number two,
I have stabbed the attendant in the parking lot down.
Five,
five,
five.
My main purpose in life is to get as many goodies as I can.
Hard five,
I'm making a lot of monies.
Most important goal,
10 plus plus.
All right,
so I'll do them later and we'll psychopath scale.
I'm,
yeah,
I feel like if you're a psychopath you would lie on this thing probably.
Yeah.
Here's the,
I think the flock,
cause I read this over before,
is that tried to be honest with it though.
Most humans aren't this self aware where you would be like I enjoy manipulating
other people's feelings.
Like you're in denial about the stuff that you do.
You wouldn't know,
but there is probably a way that you could,
you,
you could answer it somewhat,
you know,
justify to yourself more like in a way that would make sense to you instead of
saying,
I just enjoy it.
Right.
You would think there's a reason to me like for instance,
some,
some real like,
like let's say somebody who is definitely off the charts.
Yes.
On this could read things like love is Ora overrated.
Yeah.
Hundred percent.
And you know,
they get up,
they trick them.
I often desire a really clever scam.
Oh yeah.
I love a good scan.
When I get frustrated I often let off steam by blowing my top.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Wait,
what the fuck does that mean
that you get,
you get blow your top.
Hey,
yeah.
You saying crazy shit.
This is like an old timey
blow your top.
But yeah,
I don't see this.
You said you watching a lot of murder shows.
I have noticed there's so many of them.
There's so many people are watching them.
So it's not just you.
It's like I've tried to tell they're fascinating.
They're great stuff.
It is not just him.
However,
if you look at it,
Netflix Queue,
it's exclusively three primary categories,
murder,
Hitler and drug wars.
And there's very little outside of those three points of interest,
which is traveling to me,
I would say actually very misleading.
Lot more drug lords,
crime.
Very Little Hitler.
So boring.
Who Cares about Hitler?
Yeah,
that's the thing is here's the thing,
we get it.
You get it.
And it's also like I tried to watch one of them.
That's the last one I've tried to watch was a few months ago.
You know the footage,
the narrator.
It's all feels very redundant.
So what's your jam?
So you're saying you're over it now?
I do watch a lot of the drivers today.
I wish there'd be a new Hitler ready.
Right.
Drug Lords waiting for part two.
I just want to new dictator really into Janice.
You know,
somebody to kind of take the reins.
Some excitement.
Stalin's.
Interesting.
Maybe there's not as much footage on him.
Not that I've seen.
I've seen a lot of Stalin Pol Pot.
Really?
He's got some good media.
Um,
and I feel like the whole Kim family,
I wish they weren't so reclusive.
Let some more cameras then.
That'd be,
yeah.
I mean this little guy,
when he off the uncle,
there should be a whole documentary just on that.
You remember when Trump did that?
And he goes,
he was talking,
this is like a year ago.
He's like,
he's like just Kim Jong Un guy.
They'll fell.
He's like with the uncle,
like he was like giggling about it.
It's crazy.
And that's the bad press.
Trump at his best as Matt little rocket man.
Part of him was like,
you got to respect this guy.
It wasn't like,
this is reprehensible.
He's on this scale.
He's like,
do you ever admire other dictators murdering their family members?
Five
total.
Easy peasy.
Goes to sleep first between the two of you just want to be fall asleep before
the other and it used to be make flip flops.
You used to be mostly me,
but lately it's Ethan.
I used to always outlast you,
but lately I don't know what flipped,
something flipped flopped.
And do you watch television while she goes to sleep?
We always watch TV.
What's your jam?
What do you watch when she goes to sleep?
That's the real child falls asleep and Jani me.
No.
Well sometimes if I have a good one to watch it,
I like anime.
I'm not embarrassed to admit it or not embarrassed.
You just watch video games or chicks love that taught anime and video games.
Right?
That's fine.
You taking a jab at him?
Yes.
Nightmare
for her to fall asleep now see that's nice.
That's considerate.
I mean first of all I eat,
she goes to bed like fucking third grader,
you know,
good by like nine 30 but then I have to wake up and you got two kids
breastfeeding and all that shit.
Tell me what,
how,
what's your schedule?
So then,
okay,
so I tried to go to,
I pump at 10 I fall asleep.
I have to set my alarm.
I wake up at like two to pump at 2:00 AM and then I wake up at 6:00 AM to
breastfeed the kitty again.
So I don't sleep.
And those are like long sessions.
You're fully awake,
fully.
It wasn't fully awake at your weight.
And do you get resentful that Tom doesn't breastfeed?
I do,
yeah.
Especially with all the time.
I'm like,
why?
How come your tits don't make milk?
Like I just tried.
No,
we could try.
I wish.
I don't understand why the male partner has zero.
You want to put them on there today to provide for the caring of the baby.
You know,
let's carry tits and I'm saying this for resentful court and the first kid
especially,
I really hated him second baby or like this is just how it goes,
but then shit flips when that baby is a toddler and now Ellis only wants that.
That's why I'm like,
oh now it's your turn to be like the center.
It flips now.
Do you feel bad that you can't breastfeed or do you sleep peacefully and
broken up about it?
Well,
for both of your benefits,
because you are broken up,
you put your milk in and he can wake up at 2:00 AM you put your free pump milk
in the tet,
the baby can breastfeed from this.
One of our listeners,
we would really like to publicly shame,
you know,
all different types of assholes in public.
And one is,
uh,
just,
you know,
we encourage people to park like decent people.
So one of our listeners sent in this fucking guy.
So the question,
I mean,
look at this job,
the questionnaires,
the line,
just so you know,
there's the line here.
Fuck,
I have an alternate explanation because sometimes it's happened to me on,
I feel bad.
The question is who parked for first?
That's true.
That is sometimes you're forced to park like an asshole and then the other
asshole leaves in.
You look like the asshole.
That's very true.
But it's pulled in or it looks like it's impossible,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
unless,
unless before this car to the left,
that's over here.
So that's what I'm thinking.
Well,
this guy took,
I mean,
look at that.
So he left them a note on the car.
Hey asshole,
I wish whatever cunt bag you've came out of would have taught you how to park.
I wish you the most extreme explosive diarrhea known to man.
Good luck.
Love white hot.
Come dump piss on me,
beat me.
She's like,
you know,
it probably wasn't asshole par because everyone probably does.
Everyone's really loud.
I guess where I'm staying United is from where we finally found out,
I'm guessing Mexico putting money.
We saw a video of this guy and he,
he does his version of staying alive.
Can we show that course?
Of course.
Oh Wow.
So you've been that even line.
Wow.
Sounds like it might be his last.
So yeah.
First Time we saw this was this video.
Since then,
we've been sent dozens of videos of him doing youtube.
Oh well everyone just like has like will wherever they see this guy will,
he'll do his stay,
United States,
and then they'll send it into us.
So we played it over and over.
We're like,
where the fuck is this?
And we saw some writing out at a restaurant.
He was in front of that.
I looked up and it wasn't Spain.
We were like,
oh,
maybe he's Spanish.
Turns out our man dying to know is from,
his name is Omar Jackson,
but that,
that,
and he is from Bata.
He's from Morocco.
I want it to say I signed something Middle Eastern and Yep.
No sway was like if swag yeah.
Interests there,
but not to,
I mean sweet potato in that Subaru.
Yeah,
it does.
Yeah.
Uh,
Omar Potato.
Um,
anyway,
this is a,
yeah,
that's it.
He,
we've been,
we,
they keep sending us videos of him.
Well God bless us.
He's the raddest.
Yeah.
That's actually a talent man.
I mean when you watch him,
I pay money to watch him do that.
Madison Square Garden might sell out.
Uh,
cause we've looked at o'clock in the afternoon.
What about scatting?
Do you guys know what that is?
But before I know there's two meanings to scatting.
One involves shitting and there's like beep up,
right?
So there's people like Ski Dubai.
Like I would rather watch that guy do the staying alive song 10 times in a row.
I didn't watch 20 minutes of scatting.
Sure.
You don't want scatting are you like him?
No,
I liked compare staying alive guy,
because we even sent videos of people's scatting and we're like,
if you were to watch that is a show,
which one would you go to?
That guy's a legend.
He's out in the desert of all places.
So hot missing teeth.
So if someone's directly recording him and sending you guys always nine,
it's online.
All those videos are submitted for,
but I think there's,
there was a listener who actually saw him though.
So lucky.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's like a rare Pokemon.
He really is.
Yeah,
he really is.
He,
um,
and he always does his version of staying alive
and then they send us a picture of him with teeth.
No,
I almost don't want to see it.
Yeah.
Let's see it.
Oh Man.
Where's the,
it's going to ruin everything.
I know him one way.
Staying alive teeth.
Let's see.
She dare.
Don't Joe Dad staying alive,
but my gang bang.
Uh,
what that bank or what that day do you guys have local Weirdos and your
neighborhood like,
um,
yeah,
they're,
they're not wacky.
They're all scary.
What do you got?
We had a,
we had a bearded lady in our own neighborhood.
So you guys are in a really,
it's a nice,
ours is closer,
is like really close to Ventura.
So there's a lot.
Uh,
we'll get like two homeless guys who will always be there.
There's one specific corner across from cvs that has always covered in shit,
puke and garbage.
Yeah.
And I mean like,
that's right.
That's right.
There's like one spot.
Cool.
That's we'll walk by every day.
Yeah.
And um,
there's just,
yeah,
there's some transients that,
the thing about transients tonight,
I hate being like judgemental because,
you know,
I feel bad for,
I wish we took better care for homeless people in this country,
but then that scares me about these transients is that I just feel like they're
loose cannons.
Like they're unpredictable illness.
Yes.
I'm predictable.
You know,
a woman,
it can have a dollar the next minute
fucking
yeah,
the transients you're saying?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I've been in a little coffee shop with a,
a guy walked somebody in,
it was like,
get him whatever he wants.
And um,
the guy goes,
oh yeah,
thanks man.
And he orders a sandwich and a coffee.
Then he goes over and I watched him open the coffee and I'm just standing there
and takes a packet of sugar and he puts it in and then a second,
and then a third,
fourth,
he puts in like 13 packs of sugar.
And I was like,
whoa.
I didn't really fascinated.
It was like,
Holy Shit.
And then the guy goes,
here's your sandwich.
He's like,
you're not gonna fuck with me.
And flips out of the guy says he's trying to poison him.
Well,
here's my sandwich.
He throws a sandwich to the back of that.
Ah,
Shit.
It's fucked up.
Yeah.
Every,
I feel like we tried to do that to one guy and he was like,
it was going to wait outside the restaurant and we went and got food for him and
we'll come back out and he's not there.
Yeah.
That happens a lot.
There's like paranoia,
you know you're mentally ill.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But then there's entertaining homeless.
This is not what the teeth
does.
He do any other songs.
He just trying to hype himself up because life's tough.
I'm literally staying alive.
Went Bang it wet bed.
I love that.
He just does the sounds of the words seven thing.
He doesn't speak English.
I used to do that too.
And you go stay United States United States.
Did you sound out like things that like sounded like like in your head?
Yeah,
definitely.
That's,
yeah.
When we first met you look barely spoke English.
We had difficulty communicating.
Yeah.
So wait,
you're just smitten with her
when you meet her and you're,
and you start like email thing or how'd you do it?
When you mean at the Holocaust Museum.
We know that.
Yes.
And you're feeling romantic.
It's a nice setting.
Yeah.
Shout out to Hitler.
I do,
I'll have that.
Hey,
you know,
we just hit it off.
We liked each other's company obviously.
It wasn't like in a romantic way really.
I was interested.
Okay.
Yeah.
I wanted to fuck.
I think I knew that too,
but,
but I was like,
well he's going back to America,
but you know this guy,
you know,
he likes [inaudible].
She's,
she's,
she's not separate girl to give it up.
She did.
She's not looking for cheap fuck.
She's not looking for it too,
which is great.
I like,
you know,
so you just do it.
You got up.
I wasn't like aggressively trying to,
you know,
have sex with her.
No,
no,
no.
You knew that you had a good girl on hand though.
Yeah.
She's a sweet girl.
I,
you know,
which I liked.
So how do you send like,
wait,
how,
how soon after the meeting do you lead?
You only see her once we were there,
we were together for a week.
It was a week kind of activity,
but a hanging out.
We're hanging out all the time when we were there together and we just stayed in
touch via email and Skype
and face.
I didn't know what Facebook was and Ethan and all the Americans told the
Israelis,
you guys to get Facebook and they're like,
what is that?
Everyone is over 10 years ago.
It was kind of when the,
it was like a trip,
you know,
we were a group so everyone was like,
oh,
it's sad that it's ending.
So let's all exchange emails.
But I guess most of them probably didn't actually stay in contact.
And we did.
We did.
And did you send a message messages like you're trying to smash or like that
kind of thing.
She know.
And then after,
so you go back,
you see her just via Skype,
email stuff.
When do you actually physically see each other?
Yeah,
it was a while there.
I had a boyfriend year.
She wasn't even done yet.
I just came to,
I came here for two months and I went back and then another year.
Yeah.
Well I was persistent man.
Where are you?
Right.
Because a guy like me gets a girl like that interested.
You follow that thread?
Yeah.
As far as it'll take you.
And that's what made it actually the fact that here was so persistent because I,
I never thought it would be possible.
I don't know.
And then he's like,
I'm coming to Israel,
dude,
I'm moving.
I'm,
I came here first.
Oh,
you did?
Okay.
When I finished the army,
uh,
everyone in Israel,
he was really likes to take a trip somewhere after the army,
after the army for like is the commitment two years,
four years.
It's too for women or tree for three.
Four men.
Yeah.
I didn't serve,
I'm,
I agree about it.
So I finished the army and then I was like,
well everyone takes a trip somewhere.
I'll go,
I know where he is.
I'll just,
and I had a brother right here in la too,
so I was like,
I'll make that my tray.
And I like from the first moment moved in with him.
When you look,
so you were like essentially visiting,
but you moved in?
Yeah,
it went from like Skype relationship delivering together.
Okay.
And then by then we'd like,
look,
I'm trying to,
now I'm trying to get it,
I'm trying.
It was honestly the hand movements.
It was,
yeah,
there was Tom,
you know what I'm saying?
Yes.
And you know what I'm saying?
We had,
we did have,
we probably did have a consummated probably the relationship that evening.
Ah,
but what we knew that we didn't know that that was actually,
yeah,
cause either had a boyfriend for a while,
but yeah.
Um,
it was almost like,
man,
it was almost like my attempt to like,
let me really see if I really can have an Israeli guy and make my life simpler
because this whole thing is going to be so complicated.
Sure.
Everyone.
Yeah,
and like my parents hated the idea
that you were seeing that they like you're on the,
I don't know much about your,
the,
your boyfriend,
you had an Israel,
oh,
let's,
let's talk about it.
Was he interested
then?
He was okay.
No,
I see like Mossad,
like really?
No.
I mean we were all just like out the army.
No one was doing anything like six,
four
ripped.
No,
he was,
I think I read,
I saw a picture of him.
He was,
he was ripped,
right?
No,
he's okay.
He's not a thing.
Not like,
oh he wasn't a 10 she's like a nine is not a 10.
Okay.
What was he on a scale of one to 10 what was he on a scale of one to 10 who's a
10 no,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
It was embarrassed about this stuff for celebrities.
I don't even know who's a 10 I don't care about people based on their loans.
That's how I ended up with her.
You see,
I found that girl,
she's like I don't care about looks,
need a couple of good looking guys.
And they were like the dullness guys I ever met.
When I went out to check this out,
I went out with Christina and her ex boyfriend to celebrate him passing his bar
exam.
Like,
cause I knew her as a friend.
So I was part of the celebrate while you guys were dating.
So I,
while she was dating,
I was dating yet we,
Tom and I were just friends and from doing comments from doing stand up yet.
And so my ex boyfriend had just passed the bar exam and we were all going to the
Strip club across from him first we did dinner,
went through a big dinner first.
Oh right,
right,
right.
So what goes after a show night and you were already interested in that?
Yeah,
but I mean like,
uh,
so she,
I was also friends with like a couple other,
like it was a group of us who were friendly that we're comics and then I got,
I think that she didn't call me,
I think about
another friend was like,
do you want to come out to this dinner?
Like celebratory thing with Christina and her boyfriend?
And I was just like,
yeah,
sure.
I mean we went out and then we had this nice dinner.
Uh,
I think it was probably like 10,
12 people and then they were going to a strip club and I was like,
okay.
And then in the Strip club she comes up to me and is like,
Hey,
uh,
I want to get a stripper for my boyfriend.
And everybody said to ask you that,
you'd be like,
what stripper?
To get the dirt bag.
Sorry.
That's not true.
You're not,
you're not a strip club.
This guy,
this ex boyfriend mine,
I was actually on the outs with him,
which is why I would never get me.
Did you approach,
let me ask,
were you approaching Tom in a flirtatious way of like,
I'm kind of into this guy or were you genuine like I want help getting a
stripper boyfriend.
Here's the deal.
I was too too into getting rid of the current boyfriend.
Like he and I were on the outs and I was,
I wasn't looking at Dude's yet.
I was more of like unconsciously wanting to push him off of me.
And so I wanted them to get a lap dance in a weird way I think to get rid of,
like to get him interested in someone else,
if that makes sense.
It does.
And so I was talking to other male comics and I'm friends with like,
it was full charge in sickler and a,
I forget Andrew [inaudible] or something.
And I was like,
dude,
which like who's the guy that picks out the strippers and they all point to Tom
and I was like,
really fucking dirt bag.
And then you picked out the girl.
I thought it was funny.
I think it was,
I thought it was fun.
And did you pick a good one?
I don't remember.
I think I probably,
you know,
somebody like knowing myself,
I could not remembering it.
I probably would have ran with the ball.
I've been like,
oh yeah,
I'll tell you who to get sculpture.
You did.
You totally were like,
yeah,
but I liked you.
I always liked you as a comedian.
I thought you were very talented.
Like Tom never sucked at stand up.
He's a freakish people who like from the first time he did,
it was just amazing.
We were all open.
Miker is,
and I ran the show and I would have him close out every show.
I just saw almost every trial,
the closer.
He was so funny.
Even back in your relationships to use the closer he was the one that came and
set up,
right?
Yeah,
it's true.
Actually.
It's got,
I got in there,
I made it a deal.
He did get in here.
She was so young.
She was like such are so punk rock.
She's like wearing fishnets and knee high boots.
Smoke his cigarettes.
Jesus.
So angry just before therapy.
I'm like,
where you from?
I'm from La.
Everwell sucks.
True.
Okay.
Shit.
Oh,
I'm so pro la Mike,
except for Israel.
I love Israel.
Have you been there?
Now I want you to know as far as the u s I love,
it's my home.
I just don't like leaving my area.
I don't like it.
It's comfortable.
You learn as you get older.
Everyone's like this idea in their mind like the trip of a lifetime and I needed
venture.
There's nothing,
there's nothing good out there.
You know what I mean?
There's nothing out there.
No,
it doesn't.
it's not good.
What's out there?
The same shit,
except you don't.
Different foods and flavors.
Do you not like traveling?
Okay.
Yeah.
It is overrated.
I swear to God,
traveling is severely overrated.
I think you would really quick going to get my dad on the phone with you.
My Dad.
I was like,
my dad's retiring December.
God bless him.
I'm like,
very happy for him.
I go,
uh,
are you,
you know,
do you want to travel?
He's like,
I want to travel,
and I go,
you know,
somewhere like,
let's say you haven't really been to and enjoy like Italy.
He's like,
Italy,
what do I want to do that before I go?
I go,
I dunno.
You know museums are,
he's like,
Oh shit,
I hate that shit.
And he's like,
I mean,
if once you see a painting,
you saw it.
He's like,
who actually,
you have to pretend to enjoy museums buddy,
who's a honest person and museums.
It's fucking stupid.
And you only go,
you only go because you think you're supposed to like it.
There is a degree of it.
I think there's moments of enjoying the museum.
That's true.
By very rare.
No,
I'm saying so notes the moment I enjoy when I get a fucking like lunch and I sit
down.
That's true.
It does.
I think a part of it is you're telling yourself you're more sophisticated than
true.
Right?
And that you're like,
oh yeah,
this is,
this is where this was done.
And you learned something about it.
So in that moment you go,
I actually know now you're Monet did this.
I feel like I remember that.
I used to take it.
I,
uh,
when I studied abroad,
we had to go to a museum once a week with the whole class every week.
Yeah.
Because you're actually,
you're getting a,
a dosage and injection of that feeling because that you're actually walking
through the museum with an art professor who is so,
you know,
so informed that it's like getting a super tour,
and then you leave there being like,
I'm a museum guy.
Yeah.
But then you go back by yourself,
you're like,
I gotta get the Fuck Outta Ya.
Yeah.
So it's,
it's,
there's a little bit of like self manipulation I think to make you feel smart.
Go ahead.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I mean,
as a kid when you go to like,
we know as a kid we'd go to like Chicago Museum,
Natural History Museum,
those kinds of things are cool kid dinosaurs and shit.
That shit's cool.
I feel like it's just paper want to do something with themselves.
Like when you go to I'm,
and we,
we went through the Montreal and we were like,
okay,
what can we do here?
And then there's like,
oh,
there's a museum.
You know what?
I don't know.
Top rated attraction.
The whole fucking city.
Only adults do.
I other than eat.
Yeah.
The problem,
the problem with us human beings is that you go that we don't have anything to
fucking do.
This actually brings up the anniversary.
Our anniversary is coming up 10 years.
Wow.
And um,
and I was like,
I to take the trip of a lifetime,
we were talking about what to do and I was like,
let's go to an awesome restaurant.
She's like,
that's all we do.
I know.
More expensive.
What else?
And so I dunno.
She was like,
uh,
think of something more exciting.
I'm like,
God,
ideas stuff.
No,
we can't think of,
I really,
I personally really want to,
I have never been to Hawaii.
I want to go steal liquor and you have to do see that kind of travel.
I like,
I like beaches.
I like relaxing places,
good tastes good smells.
We can't do that with the babies.
You know,
what can you do?
I had that problem like every fucking weekend.
What are you going to do,
do you eat?
That's,
it doesn't really like eating.
I have to tell him what's an Ila like what's a fun adult thing?
Like if I'm like,
let's do something really fun this weekend and that's the Dan and I have a
single answer for you,
dog park,
you guys have a dog.
I don't really do that.
So the,
he's not all energetic and like driving me crazy movies when the movie is good,
but I'm tough.
Tough.
Yeah.
You know it's funny when you're saying this,
this is the exact moment.
I was like,
Oh,
I'm ready to have kids.
Cause I was like,
what the fuck am I doing with my life?
How many branches can I have?
How many fucking dinner?
And then you're like,
oh yeah,
my life.
Maybe that's what I'm saying.
Shit.
Or just like,
like when people,
like we have two children and they're young,
so we're pretty much housebound and sometimes you feel trapped and you're like,
I want to just go somewhere.
But you're like,
where am I going to go?
We never did anything before we had kids.
Now we're just home doing our kids.
You realize what?
Let's go to the Getty.
You realize that all you did was chill heart.
So just lay around.
Um,
you know what else I don't want to do.
And I think if I say it out loud,
I'm going to get like a torrent of fucking hate mail.
Like I have zero desire to see Hamilton.
I saw it.
It's wrapped,
but I only did it,
did it,
did you see it?
But I heard it was rap and I was like that fucking [inaudible] to me the other
day.
It was a realization.
She goes,
did you know him?
I was like,
of course buddy.
And the guy who plays Hamilton's like Puerto Rican just sounds terrible.
He Puerto Rico after Ethan's side when his mom,
which was a nice to hate to occur to see mom loves it.
Okay.
Ethan loved the music and he kept playing the soundtrack and I hate it.
You hate it.
She hates the soundtrack.
I love it.
You listen to Hamilton.
I love that.
She hates it.
Hate everyone hates me.
It's funny,
I've never heard it.
Is it like,
I've never heard a single term,
by the way,
I'm not insane.
If you go to the top charts,
the soundtrack of this play is like charging.
People are listening to first.
No,
I'm not insane.
But it's like catchy and it would get stuck in my head even though I hated it.
Like what's the Jam West Hamilton jam sing me like the jam.
What's the best thing?
What was one of the there there's this bit you guys want to throw up a bit.
Sure.
I don't know if we can do that.
No,
we can't throw it out there.
I'll show you a bit.
But um,
King George is this really hilarious character cause everyone's all like scrappy
hip hop,
like trying to build a nation and King George has like these really hilarious
bits where he so out of touch and he's singing like classically,
it's great.
You're gonna love rap is the one I should stop rap.
How does the sound that one's not Razzaq I'm building a country.
Is it?
Yeah.
How's it count?
I don't know.
I'm not here to defend.
I,
it's been a while.
So now I'm trying to remember how it goes.
I don't think constantly get sing a song.
I'm not,
but at any rate,
I
kind of,
that is the truth.
But,
um,
I,
my mom is into theater,
so I took her,
I had a lot of fun.
That kind of brings about one thing I wanted to ask you before.
I know it's,
you know,
we've been running for a while here,
but your mom,
would you ever date your mom
happens,
Tom,
your mom and you're my son and I fall in love with him.
I was scared to let you know too.
I am too,
both of stony adults.
If it comes down to it,
you know,
it's just like the gays there.
As long as they're all routine,
everything's fine.
So she going through jail,
uh,
they got arrested.
Is it illegal incest?
I think so.
Your mom is illegal.
Fucking your mom.
I don't think.
Wait.
Why did they go to prison for?
I think that because they put it out there instead of,
like I said,
it's just fucking,
you're fucking your mom and keeping your mouth shut.
And they had to do news fucking pieces about it.
Just fuck your mom and peace.
Just stop telling everyone that you're fucking your mom and you're fine.
I thought you were looking for an answer.
I was like,
what does anyone,
well,
it's important to know.
I'm curious.
Just like the gays.
Why have I never seen this before?
This is one of our favorites.
This is,
how do you find this stuff?
This stuff gets sent to us every week.
Mother fucker.
This is to,
we have a email that goes to their mom's podcast@gmail.com yeah,
our friends.
What's up?
I mean we don't get this stuff.
This is amazing.
This is a classic clip though.
This is not this week.
Yeah.
Just like the gays.
Will you ever date your mom ain't going where you get your son on magic being
somebody's mom and saying that 19 years you're the best thing that ever happened
to me and I really want to be with the rest of 19 yeah.
I really want to be with you for the rest of my life.
It's your son fucking loony tunes.
What is your problem?
Why do you hate love?
But you know,
in a,
in another sense,
do,
I don't know if they need to go to prison for fucking kids,
fucking kids.
He's
no better than sending it all to the same thing.
I'm with them.
They gave the follow the gaze can fuck,
then I can put my dick in any God damn thing.
Right.
That's the lie.
Including,
and especially my first approach was actually me.
Um,
what happened was we were,
we were hanging out match and hanging out and you know,
just talking and I was just laughing and I looked at her and she looked at me
and I just,
I kissed her.
Here's a real quick,
I want to die.
This is a worse than anything.
You guys watched this clip a lot.
You guys are trying to learn from you guys.
I just read you guys almost 500 episodes.
You do one episode a week.
That's incredible.
That's rose.
And I'm trying to learn from you guys.
Oh please.
We're a mess.
We're terrible.
So what really happened?
Those two are separated.
So she didn't raise him.
So they did.
Currently,
it's kind of common.
Dr Drew said that it's fallen in love with the story.
Why have we got to lock him up?
I mean that's not certainly going to help this kid psych you out.
Is it?
They're both in prison apparently according to both of them.
Oh,
I should ask them if they think it's wrong.
He's propelled by his own shit.
Get.
Yup.
I said that.
We have a lot of fan art work.
We have some that hang.
You guys have great woody Allen case.
Right?
Sooni was his stepdaughter and except she did grow up with him.
Right.
Well Craig,
that whole story is fascinating to me.
The most fascinating thing about woody Allen fucking his stepdaughter and
marrying her is that they have stayed together.
It wasn't like he's around fucking kids.
Like they're still married going on 22 years.
Yeah,
dude,
that's dude.
That is the most impressive.
So there's something I don't know about something.
He knows how to lay the wood if we're being honest,
but it looks right in the fucking name.
One time I asked my Stepdad and I went to kiss like or over Christmas I was like
19 and like he turned his head as I went to kiss him and I accidentally like
kissed him on the mouth,
you know?
And you're like,
oh well it's so fucked up unless you map.
Do you mouth kiss your parents normally?
No,
I know we will ship you.
The first time I saw that I have a neighbor across the street.
It's so upsetting.
And they said bye.
I love you.
First of all,
I don't even say I love you to my parents.
Like when we go like they say like there's families just say I love you whenever
they leave the house and that's fine.
It's sweet.
I just found a bizarre because yeah we don't talk to each other like that much
like that.
But then they kissed on the lips and I wasn't just like,
I was like,
yeah,
I've seen that too.
It's odd.
It's very weird.
Weird.
I don't know why.
I think I used to be like the instinct to with like,
cause we have babies.
You see these puffy little cheeks like you kiss cheeks or the kissing on the
mouth just seems,
it seems like out of the way.
Abnormal to romantic.
It's romantic.
It is.
Let's get some laughs going so off.
I hate this one too.
Oh
wait,
what happened in front of a baby?
Oh my God.
Why did it look like he got shot?
Is the car,
it's a car loaded.
No,
that was just his legs.
I got to see the impact again.
I'm just confused.
Yeah,
does that,
I thought it shot combustion.
Look what's happening here though.
I know.
Are you seeing this?
Wasn't there an explosion?
No.
I think my crazy,
he dropped his clipboard.
There was too
bad drive
stock.
That's what he's saying.
Look who's laughing hysterically.
She's got a great sense,
is happy.
She's been this old episode,
my husband and he got mental problems like Tom.
So you how concerned he is over here and this guy that's a girl.
That's the funniest part is that guy.
He's just like,
God damn it,
man.
We're going to be late for lunch.
Yeah,
that's what his thought was.
We're going to miss mine.
Yeah.
That guy's going to have a race horse.
This book,
I swear.
Is the scream funny to you?
Yeah.
Yep.
See,
I told you,
I told you I'm sorry to do this to the listeners and everyone.
Can we,
is there a slow motion setting?
Um,
I can do.
You can see that's what it is.
Yeah.
It's that it,
no,
no.
I don't notice anything with compassion.
Doesn't laugh upon the impact.
The sociopath.
Like Tom is laughing hysterically.
I,
we'll both take the test.
Okay.
I'll send you that.
We're all taking it.
We're going to to learn.
Yeah.
Though this is another class because all time favorite clip is a cause.
I mean it's fun.
Raj,
what would you garage work worker crushed by car.
He reminds me of a,
I could love to show you some videos now because the springs,
we'll do a cross thing of videos.
Hold on ma'am.
So wait,
are you trying to show me something?
Oh,
okay.
Get your,
actually,
this is probably the biggest hit that we've ever had.
This guy come,
this is the,
this is probably one of the most successful videos.
Okay,
you ready for it?
Here we go.
Black guys would love to fuck and fuck good.
If you're a hot black guy and you want to fuck me at 2195 if you want to move
in,
you can move in,
but you got to fuck the have any,
I need to be fucked a lot,
man.
Get rid free food,
free rent and everything else,
man.
Deal man.
Men from jail,
homeless or um,
were thug when a comment you van if Franklin Williams,
true man free rent you killed and the k fuck me his mind.
He's seen me when I come over today and try it out.
Try it out man.
Dude,
my time and try it out and I fuck up kisses.
Let me try it out.
Here's applied only as fuck man.
I'm looking for hardcore guys and meaning you want to do it and I want him to
deliver it.
I'm a hot buy.
Trash comes up.
Let's fuck good.
I admire him so much because he knows exactly what he wants and he wants it so
bad,
so bad,
and he's doing well.
He's a recording.
Such a mystery,
some shoulder movement going on.
No shirt,
right?
That wants to get fucked up bad.
Yeah.
I'm really very observant.
You guys are really observing the similar,
it took us a long time to dissect this video.
There's a lot of meth.
We had doctor drew even watch it.
Oh,
oh no.
The math or the stream.
I feel like that,
that desire to get fucked.
So that's a meth thing,
right?
I don't know,
but he definitely wants it.
I don't think I've ever wanted anything that bad.
I've never,
I don't know that I've ever been that horny.
Even when I was like,
you know,
you're a hot black guy,
black guy,
black guy.
He went,
Fuck me,
2195 if you want to move in,
you can move into,
which got fuck me,
but you've got to fuck
with me.
You get free food,
free rent,
free leasing.
The key here is the deal,
man,
and here's the deal,
man.
Here's the deal,
Man,
man,
man from jail,
homeless
people really took to it.
You know,
I love
falsely gonna Piss on me.
Beat me.
That was wonderful.
It was a lot of fun.
You guys a great community.
We really do.
They're very great.
Um,
look.
So fun.
You guys were,
are so fun.
I hope we can do it again.
I know it's a course.
Getting late in the day.
That was great.
I have done quite well.
How long has it been?
Oh,
well,
what time is it now?
It's three 40 made me throw my phone.
So I don't know.
Three,
four weeks would mean the whole episodes already over two and a half hours.
You guys have been here more than an hour and a half.
Okay.
You guys recorded or it doesn't feel long?
Yeah.
You do like half an hour right before.
Oh yeah,
we did a little bit longer.
What'd you guys talk about?
We just took clips mostly.
You know,
this weekend was sort of uneventful.
Like I took a massive shit this morning really early.
Like you didn't even talk about that response lane.
Oh my God,
we're on a,
I'm,
I'm on this Paleo Diet to lose baby weight.
And the browns have just been on believable quality.
Really good.
Easy wipes.
Yeah.
Easy wives.
Pretty,
pretty astounding.
I have like three a day that are just healthy.
And what are you doing?
Same thing.
Oh,
fucking so bread is actually what's causing all the issues?
No,
no sugar.
Yeah.
What is it?
Oh No,
I dunno.
I mean,
look,
I don't need a virgin fiber in this diet.
That's what it is.
Yeah.
You know,
uh,
Chris Delea put me on this,
metamucil.
Yeah,
that shit.
That's awesome.
Chris Takes Nice Shit,
Huh?
Hmm.
Apparently if you ask him,
that's what he'll tell you.
Apparently he said that the wife doesn't even matter to him because there was,
it's like a one wipe and he's ended it.
Did you do it bro?
I,
I take that shit like can't,
it's kind of crazy.
You get this big bottle and they're like huge pills and you're like,
oh,
just take a couple of every minute.
You're supposed to take like eight a day no matter got.
But like I started taking,
oh so happened in my,
I think maybe like,
Oh really?
Oh I'm good.
No,
I'm good.
And I started taking like two with every meal.
Oh my God.
Dude.
It's crazy.
Cause I usually have like really,
you know,
noxious shits like really toxic.
I mean not just smelling it like I'm talking.
Like sometimes you'll get shit on the side of the bowl.
You're one of those guys.
Sometimes that's how your dad is.
I always wonder how that has,
it's not every day,
it's a special occasion,
but sometimes you are wiping like your thigh.
Wow.
Let me put it that way.
Not every time,
but sometimes you're wiping your thigh and you're like really sick.
That's a Crohn's disease.
Oh yeah.
Uh,
but um,
I don't know.
That's the lady from afar video and I love that.
Um,
when they pretend to be shy,
so they do is they fought and they're like,
oh my God,
did I do that?
It's like the,
Oh
wow.
And did I do that?
Oops.
Was the gnarliest part I've ever heard in my life.
And you guys heard of,
uh,
a guy named king ass ripper?
Nope.
Like you guys are tuned into what's,
why are we not seeing these videos?
I mean private that,
you know,
higher caliber of entertainment,
the hole.
But you guys are in the youtube community.
I feel like,
cause I,
I've listened to your podcast and you'll be like,
there's like rivalries and stuff between people I've never heard of.
You're like,
this guy's whatever beef with that dude and that.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Yeah,
it's like a whole other universe.
It's that we don't even have it.
We don't know anything about it.
I really feel like 60 when I like to figure out some of that stuff,
I'm like,
oh,
these kids talking about,
yeah.
Well even when we had dinner the other night and you guys were explaining why
people want to watch other people play video games and you're like,
oh,
that might,
but you were like,
oh,
they're good at playing the games and you want to learn how they do it.
And I'm like,
oh,
that kind of makes sense now.
Well it's like watching a professional athletes.
Yeah.
It's not,
you want to learn to do it,
you're just,
you know how to play.
You're just will never be that good.
As amazing as they are.
Yeah.
I guess that's also a concept that's foreign to most people if they're not
playing all the time because they probably go like,
yeah,
they're not that like the thought is that person person's not that high
because they don't know.
You don't play a lot.
You don't go like,
that guy's great.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
When I first met Ethan,
I used to think like that too because it would put on this like starcraft,
Dota,
starcraft,
the nerdiest looking game.
You look at it and you're doing even understand what you're saying.
And they would watch people playing.
I didn't even know that existed.
So now it makes sense to me after spending time and getting to know it.
It,
I dunno,
I think it's just a first year.
Like what?
And that's because people,
it's way like the staple center,
right?
Yeah.
Like these big,
uh,
the big conventions and like the,
the competitions are now in arenas.
Yeah.
Great.
What are the on my views are crazy,
like millions of people are watching online to see a guy playing a game.
I guess you know it's,
it makes sense when you actually explain it.
It's just professional athletes.
It's the same,
same concept.
Sounds like you're doing a heavy construction.
How do you hold that much gas?
This was when he gets caught with,
damn,
he's got a,
he's got a fat ass.
Fuck.
That looks unnatural.
So you've got a whoopee cushion in there or some shit?
No,
he pulled them up or cause I don't see his ass crack.
Well yeah,
he's right.
I don't know.
That's true.
Where's his,
his sound?
It looks like he's wearing a diaper or something.
He wears.
She actually needs on,
we should have,
he gets playful sometimes and he'll do like a little leg lift or he'll do two
thumbs up as he does it.
That's it sounds like
when we lived in New York,
got like 8:00 AM outside when they're starting to do work on the street.
I love the tidy whities out a friend.
I think I can explain this phenomenon.
Never heard this.
I had a,
I have a friend,
he would,
uh,
he had a party trick.
He would lie on his stomach and he could suck air up his alley.
Oh,
you know about that?
Okay.
Oh yeah,
that's my video.
Oh,
that's my,
that's my video.
Warm it up right there.
That's you.
That's our first viral video.
That's your very first one.
So our first viral video and looking for more popular type of video,
like do you,
do you,
are you able to gauge what the audience wants?
You know what I'm saying?
Like what's the most popular thing that we make called reaction videos and it's,
but it's just me watching something or making fun of something or
like what kinds of murder?
No,
no,
no.
It's usually something stupid.
Something stupid.
Someone to make commentary is straight up comedy commentary.
Then look,
that's what you're doing.
You know,
it's a comedic take on things.
It can be on a television clip show for sure.
Yeah.
I find it difficult to be funny when I don't have,
I don't know.
I'm not good at like writing jokes.
So I feel like I need something to direct my,
yeah,
but then you ended up,
I don't want to end up convenience about that.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I don't like,
I don't,
I'm afraid of be doing like America's funniest home videos shit.
Oh yeah.
But you're not doing at all.
I'm never that guy by the way.
Who was farting?
So you saw his body for a moment.
He's also over the years been a gainer,
Uhm,
like gaining weight,
like intentionally fetishize and like he was pretty bloody fit.
This is where it looks like sky is
chosen.
This guy's got a path in life.
I'm envious of him.
Look how much,
look how much weight he's gained.
He was really,
he was really healthy.
He was.
So people are meant to watch this and get turned on.
He will come on or shown you've contacted us so many times.
One time he made a video and dedicated it to us and that was like his,
I think I see you.
Can I say something like that I really admire about him and people like him.
Your attorney turned
on?
No,
I just,
I liked it.
They know what they like.
Yeah.
I just dump money.
Really?
I'm like,
I dunno.
It was like,
I think it got up to like a thousand or something and he was just like,
he ain't in the area.
No,
I was saying like,
it wasn't like,
he was like,
that's not enough.
How about this?
He was just like,
I'm good because he,
he's,
because he does it for the love of the game is obese,
you know,
he's got rules,
right.
He's really gained a ton of it.
I like how he looks around kind of cautiously spot in this shit.
Sometimes he'll,
he'll just eat,
he'll smash like,
uh,
six egg mcmuffins and then a two liter and then he'll,
he'll get up and fart on food and then eat the farts on the food.
And Yeah,
man,
I wish I even found the videos you guys find.
I love your show.
I love that.
You know,
our shows are cut.
They're kind of similar.
Minus the youtube.
I think you're right.
Yes,
you're a sensibility in a way.
I know you guys have fucking real sleeper cells out of here.
Get him something good.
They do,
man.
They do.
They're amazing.
Remember his handle.
What was it?
Um,
was it archivally?
Yeah,
it was like I fart in Yo face.
I kept getting kicked off of services.
So funny.
So he was on youtube and lively back and forth and he was hairy and growth.
I fart in Yo face area and growth.
How many views does this have?
This,
can we read some of the comments?
Sure.
Burger King,
Gord,
let's do it.
16,000 let's see fives and he'll get the description.
Five what?
Imagine more farts.
Please.
I don't have a fetish.
I,
these are all your fans.
Probably geared.
King asked,
where can I donate money to have you make a video for me?
Also do said also if you accept,
can you do a shoutout?
Imagine working at Burger King and seeing some fat slob walk in with his own jar
of mayonnaise.
It's,
it's true.
You'd be like,
what the fuck guys?
Yeah.
Why are people so angry?
They are.
They always are.
I know,
especially on you guys put up with a different kind of look,
stamp comedians deal with hate and um,
people not liking what you do.
But I feel like in the youtube community,
man that hate just seems real fucking immediate and direct and like it is
intense,
right?
Yeah.
I guess the comments are just hard,
man.
I don't,
I try to stay away from you.
I'm reminded.
It's just,
yeah,
like as a comedian or traditional media,
there's just,
there's a layer between you and the people that doesn't exist at all on youtube.
Right.
It's just,
there's no separation.
It's the youtubers against the charter I think is the thing that doesn't exist
in the community and work.
We don't do that like wrap feuds,
rapper feuds now dude.
So you guys have like full on wrapper fuse with other youtubers?
More like,
um,
people will make videos knowing that it'll get a lot of views.
It's not like I know them or would respond to them or anything.
It's like,
like it's a feeding frenzy when something happens and then everyone's like
trolling now trolling.
They're just like making a video about it cause they know we'll get a lot views.
Gotcha.
Hmm.
Yeah.
It's totally different.
Game different.
Yeah.
It's wild.
Because that,
that whole thing of being able to quantify doesn't exist really in stand up.
You know,
you quantify like ticket sales,
take emails,
you know,
people kind of just go like that's great.
Wow,
that's a lot.
You know that person should sell more ticket.
Like it doesn't really become like,
it's not like a,
because you're,
you're,
we're not always like publicized.
Like you don't look somewhere and see tickets.
The thing is like,
um,
and also you have this like youtube algorithm,
so there's a bunch of people that are angry at us right now because we made it,
well,
whatever it does not,
it doesn't really matter what.
But so there's like this feeding frenzy of everyone making videos like talking
shit about us.
So then youtube algorithm is suggesting this video,
they're like,
you just saw this video of someone talking shit about us on the sidebar.
So it's like,
it creates this ecosystem.
Like we saw this one channel that has like no subscribers,
gets on average 300 views per video and they made a video being like a talking
shit about us,
whatever.
And it has like,
you know,
300,000 views,
cheese.
It's like they're building there,
but it's like this,
this ecosystem that the algorithm creates.
Yeah.
To do that.
So it's like,
yeah,
we're going to be like either just left here,
we got shit to say.
You would fucking go a lot of,
yes,
we're going to do a total exposed video.
But it's just,
it's like,
you know,
you live and die by that.
It's funny that people would say that.
Uh,
like make shit talking videos.
Especially because I think,
I think actually,
even though we got,
we don't like,
no,
you guys super.
Well we know you more away from that then from that.
So to us it'd be like,
why would you make a video about those tutors?
Thanks.
You know what I mean?
Like it seems weird.
It is weird.
It's weird for me.
Yeah,
it's weird.
The part,
Yeah.
It's weird because they don't really know who we are,
but they just,
you know,
uh,
it's just,
I don't know.
It's weird and that's why it's so difficult for me too because I feel like I
didn't do anything wrong.
But,
and part of it,
it's so painful sometimes are difficult,
is that you can't escape it.
Like I'll open youtube and my whole homepage,
like right now is just full of h three hate videos because youtube thinks that
because I watch three videos or anyone that watches a show,
it's like you want us to see.
So it's like they're pushing it to all of our fans and it's on my homepage
everywhere and that,
I don't know.
It's,
it's,
it's tough dude.
It is tough
being,
yeah,
that is tough.
Especially because escapable it's like the way you're right,
the way that it's designed is as opposed to heap on,
it's just what's popular.
Right?
Like it's a popularity contest in a way.
Even if it's negative popularity.
Yeah.
Whereas this standup,
like you release a special people might hate you.
They might tweet at you once and that's it.
Like,
it doesn't kind of pile on and it doesn't generally really,
you know,
it kind of goes away.
It goes away and people forget how shitty you are and then they move on to
something like this will go away
eventually.
It's just right now it's like youtube has this fucking insane algorithm that
knows that everyone sees that video was like,
what the fuck is this?
And clicks it.
Yeah.
So it's showing it to everybody,
but it's Kinda,
it's,
it's sweet in a way knowing that you can create a whole ecosystem of hate
videos and plus you guys are so kind of like newer you,
right.
You've been doing it for three years,
right
Tony?
Well,
three years full time I guess.
Right.
I feel like Tom and I have been,
I'm used to people hating us for like 15 years.
And the first of it begins when you start featuring and clubs and there's this
thing called comment cards cause the club wants to basically collect email
addresses so that they can solicit,
we make you read this shit,
they don't make you what's,
what happens is you'll as a feature act,
you're like,
yeah,
I wonder how people think about it.
I wonder if I did great.
And then you're like,
you know,
there's,
there's 10 good ones and then one horrible one and you're like,
fuck,
I just crush it.
Painful for sure.
But what happens is that dosage starts then and then you go like,
oh I need to up the antivenom a little bit.
Right.
So then,
yeah,
still hurts,
right,
like the next few times.
But you just get,
you,
you build up that immunity to it after awhile.
Cause I remember seeing a set that I did,
uh,
let us showcase at a festival was posted to something I had never had someone
with toasted.
And then like you had like some people were like,
oh funny,
you're like,
and then you see like the first like don't quit your day job duties.
Garbage.
God Damn.
Yeah.
But kind of comes with like levels of exposure.
It does.
Yeah.
I just,
I don't know why like,
well we were joking about it the other night or last night,
wasn't it?
When we got dinner?
Yeah.
Oh my God.
That would have to go.
Okay God time.
Well I was saying like for me it's feels almost like a bee sting where you get,
when you get stung more,
you become more allergic to it.
Oh,
I think I'm just,
I,
I think like I'm in a really like a
depressed place,
so maybe it feels more painful now.
Yeah.
Shut.
Yep.
Oh,
I was going to tell you if you are bummed out,
don't go read your comments.
Oh,
there's one right now telling me,
telling us we signed on.
You suck.
Yeah.
Cause I remember when like when I would be depressed and sometimes I would go,
you're like,
well,
either you're going to make yourself feel worse by looking at Twitter or looking
at the youtube comments.
Are you trying to look for a boost?
Right.
So either you're fucked either way.
Cause then you're like,
there's five good things and then one person fucking hates your guts.
So I learned in therapy when you're feeling depressed,
do not look at shit that will potentially make you feel worse.
Brain weirdly points you towards it.
Yeah.
You crave it.
It's,
and I know that and that's why it sucks because I'm right now fully disengaged
and I think that a lot of our fans are bothered by that because I'm very public.
I said I don't,
I don't read any comments.
I don't,
I'm not even on social media.
And the shame is that there's a lot of great people that I would love to connect
with,
but for me right now in the place that I am,
it's like you have to take,
if you don't want the bad,
then you can't take the bad without the good.
It's like you,
you either take the good and the bad or you don't take any of it at all.
That's true.
And I don't think I can take any of it at all.
Right.
You should listen to yourself on that.
Yeah.
And so that's why I'm trying to like really disengage.
Good.
That's good.
Yeah.
That's actually a very,
it's a very self aware and,
and,
and intelligent move on your parts and filter through what she is doing for you.
Right.
You're reading and keeping up and then if there's something he needs to see,
then he'll fucking see it.
Yep.
If not,
you don't want to see that shit.
I feel like people have used that now.
The fact that I am disengaged.
Yeah.
Whatever,
whatever.
I'm dealing with it.
Yeah.
Good for you.
Um,
all right.
Are,
are,
uh,
the students here to post stuff up.
Okay.
All right.
Do we,
um,
this was really the best.
Thank you guys for this.
We'll just do it again.
Let's do it again.
Absolutely.
You'll see that.
You'll see the place I'm working on.
I'd love to show it.
Yeah.
No.
So it guys,
if you don't know,
um,
if you're not a one of the cool kids,
uh,
the h three y where'd the name come from?
Just our initials.
Oh,
okay.
La Hackman and Ethan Edwards.
My middle name.
Age Three.
He,
he was taken,
oh gosh.
H Three H.
Okay.
Used three I street podcast.
Uh,
the gear that we've been rocking because we're models teddy fresh from the mind.
Isla Cline.
Thank you.
Um,
yeah,
you guys are a lot of fun check out there.
Uh,
amazing youtube channel.
They have HD videos and there's a Spi podcasts.
There's all kinds of stuff.
Our closing song,
we all our listeners also sending songs they make,
it was called white trash come dump by Patrick and that'll be it.
Uh Oh.
The tours on sale Friday,
I'll have a blue band post.
There's a tour video that was made this tour to promote the tour that'll go out
on the channel on Friday as well.
Go to Thomson grow.com/tour.
Those are all new 2019 dates,
uh,
on sale Friday.
And that's it.
All right.
Oh,
I'm picking up the F G tea RTD women's,
women's,
only four girls that ride till death of which there are none in the room.
That's right.
Well,
it's just factual.
It's just factual and that is that.
All right.
Bye guys.
Thank you.
Bye.
You're a hot black guy.
You want to fuck 2195 that's the one I'm moving.
You come move in
with a lot of recovery from a grant and everything else,
man.
Men from Jl Collins was red dog.
Sure,
man.
Free Reg.
So in a case,
fuck is something that I'll
come up with today.
Tomorrow.
The majority frog out
hard work
guys.
Awesome.
Awesome,
perfect.
That's fine.
Yup.